Aufgetreten.
Der Bug ist nicht mal aufgetreten.
Vielleicht war der schon längst gefixt und es waren noch ein paar verpackte Nachrichten drin oder so.
Zwei Jahre Streamson und kein Partner.
Oh ne, ich hab's gestern noch nicht gemacht, ne.
Ich hab gestern noch nicht meine Partnerbewerbung abgeschickt.
Ich weiß, ich weiß.
Aber heute nach dem Stream mach ich's.
Heute nach dem Stream wird's abgeschickt.
Weil wir gucken, wann der Stream heute vorbei ist.
Mal gucken.
Äh, den, den ich gestern gehostet hab, hat den zufällig noch eine Weile geguckt.
Ich hab nämlich mal, ich hab nämlich mal am Ende, irgendwann als ich ins Bett gegangen bin,
hab ich irgendwie den Stream aufgemacht, dann war der immer noch on.
Der war, der war echt ausdauernd.
Der hat irgendwie sechs Stunden mindestens geboren.
Also so lange am Stück könnte ich nicht hier Progress machen.
Ich glaub, die Musik ist immer noch ein Ticken laut, ne.
Ja, so ist das gut.
Vielleicht muss ich auf Deutsch programmieren.
Ja, das wird's sein.
Das wird's sein, gehe ich auch von aus.
Äh, was hat man als Partner für Vorteile?
Ich zeig's dir.
Naja, nicht nur.
Also, du kriegst, also du kriegst, du kannst abonnieren und du kriegst halt Emotes.
Das ist so das Größte.
Das Wichtigste.
Du kriegst, du kannst damit Geld verdienen.
Nämlich Leute abonnieren dürfen.
Es gibt drei Abostufen.
Es gibt einen für, es gibt einen Tier-1, 2, 3 Sub.
Das kostet glaube ich 5 Dollar, 9 Dollar, 24 Dollar?
Ich hab, ich hab ehrlich gesagt noch nie jemandem einen Tier-3 Sub gegeben.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Ähm, 24, ja okay.
Okay, 24,99, das ist ja im Endeffekt 25, ähm, huge money, ja.
Und man kriegt Emotes für, das ist eigentlich das Wichtigste bei der ganzen Geschichte.
Ich weiß, man kriegt bestimmt noch jede Menge andere Karten.
Ich glaub man kann Bits und cheeren und, und, und hast du nicht alles gesehen, aber das
Wichtigste ist eigentlich Emotes.
Warum ist denn hier so ein großer Platz bei Google?
Ach, wegen Ihrem Karten?
Ach, wegen Ihrem Kack-Logo?
Oh, huge money.
Hyokun, huge, massive.
Ist dann drei Abos, krieg ich dann 15 Dollar.
Moment, das stimmt ja noch nicht, wenn ich 15 Dollar krieg.
Ich krieg ja nur die Hälfte.
Ähm, welche Programmiersprache kannst du?
Ja, das müssten wir mal aufnehmen.
Ich müsste mir da mal Gedanken zu machen und das müssten wir mal aufnehmen, weil die Frage kommt oft.
Lass mal, das machen wir jetzt mal schnell.
Ähm.
Ich muss mal kurz, kurz in mich gehen.
Was für Programmiersprachen kann ich denn?
Äh.
Leute, ihr habt, ihr habt mich ja C und C++-Wursten sehen.
Würdet ihr sagen, das darf ich unter Kannich abstempeln?
Ich mein, Kannich heißt nicht, man ist Experte oder so.
Sondern ich krieg damit halt was hin.
Okay, fangen wir mal an.
Ähm.
Proggers.
Sprachen.
Ich mag, ich mag ja besonders Tabs, die automatisch aufgehen.
Ja, nein, ja, nein.
Also aktuell ist 2 zu 2.
Ich, äh, sag mal ja.
Also.
Ähm.
Meine Lieblingssprache, also meine Lieblingssprache ist zweigeteilt.
Zweigeteilt.
Übrigens, äh, mal, mal eingeworfen.
Ne, verrate ich nachher.
Verrate ich nachher.
Äh, oder was heißt verrate ich?
Frage ich euch danach.
Ähm.
Also meine Lieblingssprache bin ich so zweigeteilt.
Richtig, richtig debateclock.
Ähm.
Also meine Lieblingssprache bin ich zweigeteilt.
Vom Framework und an sich drumherum ist es, ist es, äh, ist wie Sharp mit .Net.
Allerdings, ich mag auch Ruby sehr gerne als Programmiersprache.
Leider ist Ruby in den letzten Jahren so ein bisschen, ähm.
Abgekackt.
Also neue Ruby-Projekte gibt's eigentlich nicht mehr so, also ganz wenig.
Wenn man nämlich mal hier auf GitHub sucht nach, keine Ahnung, Temp.
Wir gehen einfach mal von da aus.
Temp gibt's in jedem Programm.
Und da gucken wir mal.
Hier, guck mal da unten.
Ruby.
Ruby ist, ist ganz, JavaScript ist ganz oben.
Und danach kommen die üblichen Verdächtigen.
JavaScript ist ganz oben, ist klar.
Gefolgt von Java und Python ist klar.
HTML.
So.
C++, PHP, CSS.
Ruby.
Vor ein paar Jahren sah das noch ganz anders aus.
Also mit, mit neuen Sachen.
Da war Ruby, äh, voll angesagt, ja.
Aber es, es ist ein bisschen abgekackt.
Das liegt auch daran, weil Python so erfolgreich ist im, im AI-Sektor, im, im Forschungssektor, im Web-Anwendungssektor.
Python ist, hat sich ziemlich, ziemlich breit gemacht.
Und ist auch eine ziemlich gute Sprache.
Wobei ich, also, wir, wir können ja noch mal, ich könnte ja noch mal dahinter schreiben,
wie gut ich einschätzen würde, äh, progress, wie gut ich einschätzen würde, dass ich
die ganzen Krams kann.
Das machen wir danach.
Okay.
Ganz wichtig, wenn man was mit, mit Linux macht.
Shell.
Shell, in der Regel Bash, weil, äh, äh, die paar Sachen, die Bash da dazugefügt hat,
wie diese Fake-Arrays in, in, in, in der Shell und so was, sind schon ganz praktisch.
Ähm, ja, C, C++.
Wobei da, wie gesagt, bin ich kein, kein großer Profi.
Äh, JavaScript, CSS, HTML.
Wobei ich da jetzt auch nicht so der, so der krasse Owner bin.
Äh, Groovy kann ich noch.
Das ist die einzige Java-Sprache, die ich kann.
Ähm, kann ich da noch?
Kann ein bisschen PowerShell.
OKS.
Ähm.
Vergesst die Hälfte.
Jetzt PHP, ja.
PHP.
PHP hab ich damals für meinen Battlefield-Server, hab ich so eine Stats-Page gemacht, falls
irgendjemand damals auf meinem Battlefield-Server gespielt hat.
Da hab ich eine Stats-Page für die Leute gemacht im PHP.
Alle, die auf dem Server gespielt haben.
Das war eigentlich ganz nice.
Also jeder hatte quasi so, so ein Stats-Profil.
Wir wurden getrackt.
Äh, Rust.
Rust.
Rust hab ich auch schon was mitgemacht, ja.
Ähm.
Go, nein.
Go hab ich, ich hab ein bisschen mal rumgespielt mit Go, aber da würd ich nicht sagen, dass
ich damit was auf die Reihe kriege.
Dein BF3-Stream.
Server.
Nee, viel, viel früher.
Das war ein Xbox-Server.
Nein, Java kann ich nicht.
Äh, das war ein Xbox-Server.
Da hatte ich eine PHP-Seite gemacht.
Man konnte, man kann ja...
Warte mal, war das ein Xbox-Server?
Nee, Schwachsinn.
Xbox-Server konnte man gar nicht drauf connecten.
Dart.
Dart kann ich auch nicht.
Ich weiß das Dart und Flutter-Skala auch nicht.
Es war, das war...
Na, Assembler würde ich nicht sagen.
Da würde ich nicht können.
Also ich mein, wir können's mal dabei schreiben, ja.
Wir können, wir können, wir können mal...
Ich schreib, ich schreib wie gut ich denke, dass ich was kann.
Dahinter.
Aber, also...
Man hat's ja das letzte Mal gesehen, das war sehr...
Kompliziert.
Wo ich da mal was in Assembler krieg.
Wo ich da mal was in Assembler gebastelt hab.
Ja, Dart und Flutter ist voll angesagt.
Ich hab gesehen, die haben auf der letzten...
Das ist übelst...
Übelst huge.
Ja.
Also, das ist, ähm...
Richtig, richtig nice.
Die haben auf ihrer letzten Konferenz...
Haben die angekündigt, dass, ähm...
Flutter jetzt für Desktop funktioniert.
Und nicht damit, die haben irgendwie...
Hier, irgendwie, genau.
Das haben die...
Nee, nee, nee.
Ich weiß nicht, ich weiß nicht, wie das heißt.
Ich hab letztens ein Video zugesehen.
Da haben sie gezeigt, dass du jetzt ganz offiziell...
Zwar offiziell ist es noch Beta.
Aber, dass du jetzt Desktop-Anwendungen mit Flutter machen kannst.
Linux Mac Windows.
Das ist extrem nice.
Das ist wirklich nice.
Weil, ganz ehrlich...
Eine Sache, die der Welt wirklich noch fehlt...
Ist ein ordentliches Cross-Platform-GUI-Framework.
Das nicht Elektron ist.
Und das nicht C, C++ ist.
Es gibt ja nix.
Ihr sagt nicht, es gibt was.
Weil, wenn ihr sagt, es gibt was, dann müsst ihr auch sagen, was.
Und meiner Ansicht nach gibt es nix Gescheites.
Es gibt Elektron und es gibt Qt.
Das war's.
Cross-Platform.
Ernst zu nehmen.
Ich hab nix prinzipiell gegen C++.
Allerdings ist C++ nicht die Sprache, in der ich jetzt...
Gerne komplette Anwendungen mache.
Ich hab letztens einen Vortrag gesehen.
Qt ist übelst nice.
Das ist...
Das ist doch nicht...
Das ist, ich würd sagen...
Mit meinem Lieblings-GUI-Framework.
Und Qt geht, weil es sehr viel Eigenes macht, was nicht so Standard-C++-mäßig ist.
Ja, Qt-Chat.
Ja, ja, ja, genau.
Aber ich hätte gerne noch irgendwas...
Was anderes dazu.
Aber Qt ist wirklich nicht schlecht.
Die wissen leider nicht so genau, was...
Ich finde das ein bisschen verwirrend.
Vor allem, weil sie jetzt auf ihrem QML-Trip mit...
Mit JavaScript und so sind.
Das finde ich auf der einen Seite gut.
Und auf der anderen Seite wieder ein bisschen doof.
Weil das ist...
Das ist ganz nice.
Aber dann musst du dann C++-interopt damit machen.
Was dann wiederum irgendwie ein bisschen eklig ist.
Also...
Es wäre schön, wenn es da was aus einem Guss gäbe.
Und was richtig nice wäre...
Wenn es auch ein paar Bindings für unterschiedliche Sprachen geben würde.
Und ich hab letztens einen...
Einen...
Web...
Wie nennt man das?
Wie nennt man so einen Konferenz-Mitschnitt?
Einen...
So ein Wort von einer Konferenz gesehen.
Da hat einer...
Plazor gezeigt.
Das ist von Microsoft nen...
Nen...
Kennt ihr das?
Das ist von Microsoft Plazor.
Das ist nen ASP.NET quasi für den Browser.
Also so..
Ganz merkwürdige Geschichte.
Das ist quasi nen Web Assemblery kleinzeit...
ASP.NET Ding von Microsoft.
So.
Und das haben sie gezeigt.
wie man das nicht nur im Browser laufen lassen kann, sondern auch mit Flutter.
Was im Umkehrschluss heißen würde, wenn das ordentlich funktioniert,
könnte man in Zukunft tatsächlich halbwegs ordentliche Internetanwendungen,
Cross-Plattform-BUI mit Flutter machen.
Also ich meine, ganz ehrlich, Flutter ist super nice, was ich gesehen habe,
wie man das Interface erstellt.
Das ist ein bisschen wie HTML, plus ohne den ganzen Crap drumherum.
Es ist wirklich nice.
Und wenn da, ist die Sharp und .NET runter, das wäre übelst nice.
Übrigens denkt daran, wenn ihr völlig was übersehe, schreibt es mit AdWubLores,
weil sonst taucht es in meinem Tool nicht auf.
Der Pluton haben sagt, ich denke, dass MSBit.NET 5 was Cross-Plattform rausbringen wird, ankündigen.
Da habe ich meine Zweifel, ob Microsoft Cross-Plattform,
GUI probieren wird.
Die sind sich ja unter Windows noch nicht mal einig, was für eine GUI jetzt angesagt ist.
Ey, Windows ist der GUI Wildwuchs, ich weiß gar nicht, was mit Microsoft abgeht.
Windows ist der GUI Wildwuchs und Technologien Wildwuchs Deluxe.
Guckt euch nur mal in Windows an, ihr müsst hier nur mal irgendwie Control eingeben,
altes Control Panel, neues Control Panel, komische neuen, komischen neuen Dings-Anwendungen,
ähm, wie heißen sie?
Ups, dann dieses komische Fenster-Shake-Feature.
Ah, wie heißt der Kram nochmal? Ich habe es vergessen.
Äh, die haben auch alles für jeden Scheiß eigene Namen.
Fluent Design, nee, nee, nee.
Doch Fluent, Fluent Design ist das, oder?
Was sie sich jetzt neu ausgedacht haben für UWP.
Was du jetzt allerdings auch in WPF und so verwenden kannst.
Ähm, also Windows ist von Microsoft Seite übelst nicht, ich glaube Fluent Design nennt sich das Ganze jetzt.
Ähm, ja, das ist das, dass die Anwendungen jetzt quasi so schön transparent sind und hast du nicht gesehen.
Zumindest Windows an sich ist schon der übelste Wildwuchs, was, was, ähm, GUI angeht.
Du hast ja auch dann selbens wiederum zig verschiedene Technologien, die du verwenden kannst unter Windows,
die Microsoft supportet.
Ich meine, du hast die uralte Windows-Geschichte, du kannst ja immer noch Windows von Hand machen, ja.
Dann hast du quasi als Rapper nochmal Windows vorhanden.
Porn drumherum.
Dann hast du diese, diese habe ich nie verwendet, diese MFC-Geschichte für C++.
Dann hast du irgendwelche internen, äh, äh, C++-Geschichten, die beispielsweise Word verwendet.
Dann hast du, äh, WPF.
Dann hast du UWP.
Ähm, es ist, es ist ja so schlimm, Microsoft verwendet den Krams ja selbst noch nicht mal konsequent.
Der Visual Studio Installer ist, glaube ich, Electron.
Korrigiert mich, wenn ich falsch liege.
Ähm, und es ist, es ist ganz, es ist super, wir.
So, und nachdem Microsoft das ja selbst noch nicht mal geschissen kriegt unter Windows,
mal für einheitliches GUI und eine einheitliche GUI-Technologie zu sorgen,
weil UWP ist ja immer noch keine Alternative für ordentliche Anwendungen.
Du kannst in UWP keine Screenshots machen.
Ich meine, 2019.
Das ist der Witz, oder?
Ja.
So.
Und deswegen glaube ich nicht, dass Microsoft einen Cross-Plattform-GUI-Framework anbieten wird.
Ich würde es ihnen zutrauen, also sie schaffen würden, sie können, tun die das auf jeden Fall.
Ähm, aber nachdem die es ja noch nicht mal auf ihrer eigenen Plattform geschissen kriegen,
habe ich meine, habe ich meine Bedenken, dass Microsoft das Cross-Plattform-Geschissen kriegt.
Zumal unter Mac, unter Mac sieht alles, was nicht, äh, Cocoa heißt das, glaube ich, gell?
Das Standardzeug von Mac.
Ähm, für alles, was nicht Native Mac ist, sieht unter, Native Mac und zum Teil noch Browser, ja, äh, sieht alles scheiße aus.
Das Problem hast du auch.
Guckt euch mal eine GTK-Anwendung unter Mac an.
Ey, das ist ja, das, das, das, das, mir fällt kein Vergleich zu einem, wie das aussieht.
Das sieht aber auf jeden Fall Mist aus.
Oder guckt euch eine GTK-Anwendung unter Windows an, das reicht schon.
Guckt euch eine Qt-Anwendung unter Mac an.
die sieht dann ein bisschen aus wie Mac, aber
schreit an allen Ecken und endlich bin ich
Mac. Was ist
deiner Meinung nach beste GUI für C-Sharp?
Also,
ganz ehrlich,
ich bin eigentlich
für UWP,
allerdings
das Problem mit UWP ist,
dass du halt es nicht gebrauchen
kannst für ordentliche Anwendungen.
Wie gesagt, du kannst bis heute keine Screenshots machen
in UWP.
Deswegen
bin ich in dem Fall für Windows Forms,
weil es einfach ist
und
WPF kann auch einfach sein,
aber WPF machen sie immer so eine
riesige Glaubensgeschichte drumherum.
Bei WPF ist es so,
wenn du in WPF in deine
GUI-Dateien Code
reinschreibst, flippen die ganzen
WPF-Best-Practice-Leute instant aus.
So nach dem Motto, okay, ich brauche eine App,
die ein Fenster hat und
mir drei Zahlen anzeigt,
dann schreit da WPF,
direkt rum, wenn du das in den Code-Behind machst.
Dann sagt der WPF-Typ dann, oh mein Gott,
wie kannst du das in die Code-Behind-Datei schreiben?
Da musst du mal hier mindestens MVVC
und zig, dreißig Milliarden
Frameworks dazwischen machen, dass du
ein Fenster starten darfst.
Deswegen, ich bin für Windows Forms.
Windows Forms ist eine gute Abstraktion
über Native-Windows-Geschiss
und an sich werden wir
UWP aber am liebsten.
UWP ist sehr angenehm zu verwenden,
allerdings
ist das Problem, dass UWP halt vieles nicht kann,
was man braucht.
Ja, und
leider, man muss sich ja mal überlegen,
wo uns das Ganze hingebracht hat.
Das hat uns unter anderem dahin gebracht,
dass die beste Alternative
für Desktop-Apps
mittlerweile nicht etwa Qt ist.
Qt ist keine Alternative, schlicht und ergreifend,
weil es
ganz billig gesagt, weil es
C und C++ ist.
Das ist von der Technik her nicht schlecht,
allerdings der Verbreitung tut es jetzt nicht gerade gut.
Ähm, ja.
Und Qt hat immer noch
paar
paar Viren, ich war, ich
hab da mal eine Weile relativ viel mitgemacht,
ein paar Viren, was die unterschiedlichen Plattformen angeht.
Zum Beispiel
konnte der
das Textfeld in Qt
lange Zeit
keine
Emojis von Windows einfügen
und sowas
und dann hat es das Textfeld gebackt und so.
Das ist ganz merkwürdig, ja.
Aber da sind sie dabei.
Was auch ein Problem ist, wenn du Qt startest
unter Windows, warte mal, hab ich das, hab ich das installiert?
Äh, MaxSightTrack
soll es am Start, ich zeige euch das mal kurz.
Wir machen jetzt, wir machen jetzt eine
Mini-Qt-Anwendung.
Ich zeige euch mal, was ich meine mit
Viren.
Wobei, gibt's das nicht vielleicht?
Leute, ihr müsst euch merken, was ich mich
bei einem Sidetracken lasse,
dass ich dann wieder das
noch aufgreifen kann.
Nee, gibt's nicht.
Da müsst ihr das runterladen.
Ja, aber guckt mal, wo haben uns das
letztendlich hingeführt?
Dass Qt keine Alternative ist,
dass Microsoft nicht genau weiß, was
bei ihnen abgeht, GUI-technisch,
dass Apple prinzipiell
den eigenen Crap macht,
zum Beispiel mit Metal als Grafik-API,
dass es
immer mehr
Mobile-Zeugs gibt
und dass es kein, schlicht und ergreifend,
vielleicht Flutter in Zukunft,
kein ordentliches,
Cross-Platform-GUI-Framework gibt.
Woran ist das hingeführt?
Dahin, dass die beste Alternative, die wir
aktuell haben für Cross-Platform-GUI-Anwendungen,
die auch ordentlich funktioniert,
Elektron ist. Also im Prinzip
ein Chrome in einem eigenen Fenster
mit jeder Menge JavaScript drumherum.
Ich finde immer nie den Download-Kopf-Knopf
für Qt. Das ist super, super
hidden.
Was, bei Mac gibt's doch Unity?
Ich weiß nicht, was Unity unter Mac ist.
Ich kenne nur Unity als Game-Engine.
Und ja, der Witz ist, dass Qt als Game-Engine ist.
Pass mal auf! Ich hab sogar schon ernsthafte Diskussionen
drüber gehört, wo Leute gesagt haben, sie wollen
Unity, also die Game-Engine,
als Cross-Platform-GUI-Framework verwenden,
weil es nichts gibt.
Nichts gescheit, also nichts gescheit
native gibt.
Der Witz macht zwar keiner, der irgendwie dabei
verstanden ist, aber allein schon
sieht man, wie verzweifelt die Leute sind.
Äh...
Qt Online Installer, blablabla...
Skip. Ich zeig euch jetzt nämlich mal, was das Problem damit ist.
Ähm... Ich hoffe, das Problem ist, dass ich jetzt mal
das Problem gibt, sonst ist es gut, wenn es das Problem
nicht mehr gibt.
Also, die Plattform-Viren, die Qt
so ein bisschen hat.
So. Next.
Äh... Was ist denn die aktuellste Version?
Qt 13?
Äh... Ich brauch Qt 13
für... Jaja, komm jetzt mal nicht die ganze Zeit.
Ich brauch Qt 13 für...
Microsoft
Compiler, 64bit...
Leicht.
Und Qt Creator
soll er installieren. Das geht
schnell, der Downloader. Das ist, äh...
What? No.
Abort.
Nicht abbrechen. Ach, jetzt hat er wieder
mein OBS gekillt.
Geht's wieder? Geht's wieder?
Jetzt geht's wieder, ne?
Ich musste, ich musste den
Installer-Fart ändern.
Wo ändert man den
Installer-Fart? Next.
Skip.
Next.
Und jetzt einfach
nur, dass ich euch zeigen kann, was, wie Qt
rumspackt. Ach, da. Ähm...
Nicht C Doppelpunkt Windows,
sondern, äh, Stream.
Gut.
Oh.
Next.
Oh. Für Microsoft Compiler.
Ich hoff, den hab ich überhaupt installiert.
C Doppelpunkt... Ah, jaja.
Lull.
Inst...
Fix. Ihr habt keine Ahnung,
was ich meine, ne? Ist schon klar.
Die hatten, die hatten ewig,
wirklich ewig,
jahrelang, hatten die das Problem,
unter Windows, unter
Linux war das kein Problem, dass sie das
Resize gelaggt hat.
Aber nicht einfach nur gelaggt, sondern,
sondern wie, äh,
wie Crysis auf dem Rechner von
2000.
Das war wirklich so, sogar,
sogar, das ist dann auch
schwarz geworden und sowas.
Moment, Moment, welches, welches
Render-Backend verwende das
standardmäßig? Weil,
die Sache war die, ähm,
Moment, Moment, das müssen wir jetzt mal ausprobieren.
Ähm,
Alter, wenn ich,
wenn ich sowas hier schon zähne,
wer,
wer hat sich überlegt,
vom C++
Standardgremium,
dass das, dass das
eine schöne Syntax ist?
Das sieht richtig, und das ist noch nicht mal schlimm.
Das ist, das ist noch schön, das ist schön,
das ist ein schönes C++.
Das ist noch nicht mal schlimm.
In C++ gibt's ja so komische Dinger wie,
äh, sowas wie, wie
Kunst und, und Blub und so Dinger,
wo ich mir denke, was soll das überhaupt sein?
Ähm,
da sind irgendwelche R-Values
und sowas, äh, warte mal.
Also,
um euch jetzt nochmal zu erklären, was das Problem war,
in, in alten Versionen hatste,
warum will das Netzwerk
Zugriff? Piss dich.
Netzwerk, ach so fürs Debuggen,
wahrscheinlich, ähm,
ah, habt ihr's gesehen?
Es hat geflimmert,
das hat, die haben das Problem immer noch.
Es hat geleckt oder geflimmert,
je nachdem, was man gemacht hat.
Ich glaub, wir müssen, wir müssen da mal,
wir müssen da was, was reinmachen.
Rectangle, oh, ich kann kein QML
aus'm Kopf, äh,
äh, ich kann,
die Q aus'm Kopf, keine Ahnung,
500,
ja, okay, Moment, ich muss mir mal
eine QML Rectangle
mit Background kopieren, oder wir machen
einfach, wir können einfach ein neues Projekt machen, weil
das hat, das hat, das hat gebackt.
Du hast den Q, du hast den Q das Problem,
entweder hat das Resizen geleckt wie Hölle,
oder der Background hat
geflimmert ohne Ende.
Ja, Rectangle
gibt's da.
Äh, Qt Creator ist eigentlich,
ne, ne, ne,
ne, ne, das, das ist okay.
Ähm,
Anchor, Anchors,
äh, boah, boah,
wir machen das jetzt einfach so.
Ich will jetzt heut gar kein Qt
programmieren, aber,
ne, die haben das gefixt.
Die haben das gefixt.
Machen wir mal ein anderes Beispiel.
Das wäre extrem nice.
So, eben haben wir 13 genommen,
wir nehmen jetzt mal 10.
Ach, ne, das ist
minimal required.
Die haben's gefixt.
Ich glaub's nicht.
Wahnsinn, nach 5 Jahren.
Okay, das Default Font
Rendering sieht immer noch Mist aus, aber das kann man umstellen.
Die haben's gefixt.
Ey, das ist echt, das ist echt nice.
Also, das Problem war, dass die bisher
immer, dass die übelstes
Resize-Lag hatten,
aber, aber
richtiges Lag. Ich muss, das muss ich mir
nach dem Stream oder so, muss ich mir das nochmal ordnen.
Einmal nix, das fehlt vielleicht. Machen wir mal
ne kleine Qt-Anwendung und gucken uns das an.
Die Qt-Anwendung nennen wir dann
aber Ayaya und
lassen das Ding ne Ayaya-Animation
abspielen oder sowas.
Ähm...
Was ist im Chat los, Alter?
So, und das andere Problem war,
wenn das Resizen mich geleckt hat,
dann, ähm,
hat der Hintergrund geflimmert wie Sau.
Und es hat auch unterschiedlich
geleckt, ob man so resized oder
oder so resized.
Übrigens, jetzt, jetzt, ähm,
eine Frage. Hat jemand ne Idee,
warum es
unterschiedlich laggt, ob man
so resized
oder so resized?
Ist eigentlich logisch,
wenn man drüber nachdenkt, aber so ein bisschen
Interaktion hier.
Wenn man so resized, war das Lag besser,
als wenn man so resized.
Erdkrümmung, ja fast.
Geht schon in die richtige Richtung.
Ich schenk mir mal was Neues
zu trinken ein. Das Problem ist,
also was ich mir denken kann,
was nicht offiziell im Backtracker steht,
das Problem ist,
dass du die ganzen Grafik-Background
gedönst,
ähm, mal angenommen, du hast
nen Buffer für alle Pixel, ja,
du kannst super
den vergrößern,
also, ne,
du hast hier 0,0-Koordinate oben links,
du kannst ohne Probleme den Buffer
vergrößern, was dran hängen.
Wenn du allerdings jetzt hier oben
quasi den Punkt, wo 0,0 ist,
veränderst, dann musst du, glaub ich,
die ganze Anwendung, den kompletten Buffer resizen.
Ich denk mal, dass sowas
der Hintergrund gewesen sein muss,
dass da, zumindest, man konnte das fixen,
in Qt früher auch schon,
hallo, Dark, Tidus,
man konnte das in Qt früher auch schon fixen,
während man,
wurde mal kurz black, ja, aber das ist nichts
im Vergleich zu früher.
Das ist nix, das hat, das hat
vorher, das, das, das,
das hat vorher
geflimmert, wie wenn einer,
ähm,
wie die, kennt ihr die, die,
die in Half-Life, kennt ihr die,
diese Headcrab-Zombies?
Da gibt's im ersten Level von Half-Life
sowas, wo sie damals schon Probleme
hatten für Leute mit Epilepsie,
wo die, wo so flimmert, so sah das
aus im Hintergrund, wenn du das
resized hast früher, wobei,
unten könnte es noch ein bisschen
flimmern.
Nee, das ist okay, das ist echt okay.
So, und was du früher machen konntest, ist, oder machen
musstest,
du musstest entweder sagen,
ähm, ich will Software-Rendering haben,
dann konntest
du keinen Webbrowser verwenden.
Weil der Qt Webbrowser,
also die, die Qt
Webengine, funktioniert bloß
mit, ähm,
mit nem 3D-Renderer.
Ich muss jetzt mal kurz
gucken, dass ich das richtig zusammen,
zusammenkriege. Du konntest auch das
Backend umstellen,
auf, also standardmäßig ist es nämlich
OpenGL. Hatten sie die ganze Zeit.
Ah, wir gucken mal, wir stellen
es mal auf OpenGL um. Vielleicht, vielleicht
ist es dann, vielleicht
ist das Problem wieder drin. Ich weiß allerdings nicht mal,
wie das funktioniert hat.
Ähm, standardmäßig
haben sie früher OpenGL zum Rendern verwenden, das war
unter Windows Crap. Vielleicht sind doch einfach die Nvidia
Treiber mittlerweile besser. So, und dann
konntest du es zurückstellen auf
x11, das hat nichts gebracht, auf 10
hat nichts gebracht. Erst mit 9
hat es halbwegs funktioniert.
Allerdings,
dass es mit DirectX verwendet
werden konnte,
musstest du einen,
ähm,
einen OpenGL
zu
DirectX-Wrapper
irgendwie verwenden, nannte sich
Angle. Und damit lief's
echt gut, aber damit hattest du dann Probleme, dass
wieder andere Sachen nicht richtig funktionierten. Aber es war voll
für den Arsch. Es war richtig kacke.
Das heißt, wenn es jetzt defaultmäßig richtig gut
funktioniert, wäre echt
sehr nice und wird das
wieder dazu führen, dass sich tatsächlich wieder mehr mit Qt
machen wird. Wie konnte, wie hat man
in Qt nochmal das Backend umgestellt?
Ähm,
zeugst du noch was?
Ich zeug, also in letzter Zeit
spiel ich eigentlich jede Menge olle
Zeug wieder.
Ähm,
ich muss mal gucken, wie man das umgestellt hat.
Wie man OpenGL,
ich muss mal gucken, wie man das, ich will's
jetzt nämlich mal auf OpenGL, auf
OpenGL umstellen und gucken, ob der Bug immer
noch da ist. Ja, Qt
Engel, ne Engel-Plattform wollten wir nicht.
Ich will nicht Engel, ich will ganz
normal OpenGL verwenden.
Die ganzen APIs kann sich doch kein Mensch im Kopf
merken. War das, war das
Z-Attribute irgendwas in der Richtung, dass
man sagen konnte, GL?
Ne, oh
fuck.
Wie hat man dem Ding nochmal gesagt, dass der
OpenGL
verwenden soll?
Origin braucht Qt Webgedöns. Ja, ja, Origin ist
eine Qt-Anwendung mit Qt
Webengine drin. Ich hab da sogar mal ein Video drüber gemacht.
Wo ich die Chrome-Developer-Tools
für Origin eingeschaltet hab.
Das war eigentlich ganz lustig.
Da konnte man in Origin in den
Chrome-Developer-Tools rumklicken.
Force OpenGL
Und ich muss hier leider schon mal kurz in mich gehen.
Ah, ja.
Das da.
Da konnte man das auf jeden Fall
forcen, dass es OpenGL verwendet.
So, und mit OpenGL hatte das halt
riesige Probleme unter Windows.
Die letzten Versionen. Mal gucken, wie es jetzt ist.
Und das ging aber schnell.
War das jetzt?
Ne?
Das ist ja nice. Das funktioniert.
Huge.
Okay, ich bin begeistert.
Ich bin begeistert.
Das hat absolut nichts mit dem zu tun,
was ich heute machen wollte. Aber ich bin
begeistert, dass es die Probleme nicht mehr gibt.
Schieben geht auch. Resizen geht auch ohne
Probleme. Es laggt auch.
Google Mail oder sowas. Was war das?
Glaube ich.
Was auch immer.
Ähm.
Kannst du was
Kannst du was zu Web-
Entwicklung in 2019 sagen?
Speziell was aktuell State of the Art
für Backend und Frontend ist?
Also ich bin jetzt nicht der Super-Experte,
was Web-Anwendungen angeht.
Wie man ja unter anderem auch hier sieht, dass meine Emotes rumbacken.
Wobei die Emotes sind eh nur gefaked.
Die kommen gar nicht so direkt aus der Anwendung. Aber
nicht weiter sagen.
Also aktuell
sehe ich zwei große Trends, was
Web-Entwicklung
angeht. Zum ersten Mal nach wie
vor, also Frontend.
Zum ersten Mal nach wie vor
natürlich ganz viel JavaScript und so Zeug
wie Angular, React und Vue.
Das ist nach wie vor
angesagt. Vue ist jetzt
das neueste da von den drei
großen. Allerdings
mögen das die Entwickler.
Allerdings im Business-Bereich ist es
eher React und Angular, was die machen.
Die meisten da verwenden.
Falls ihr Web-Entwickler hier habt, könnt ihr gerne
im Chat was zu schreiben, wie ihr das seht.
Der zweite
Trend bei
Web-Entwicklung im Frontend, den ich sehe
ist, dass jetzt so
nach und nach immer mehr Sachen kommen,
die
es schon lange gibt, die allerdings
ihren Weg in den Browser finden
über WebAssembly. Also sprich
zum Beispiel gibt es jetzt ja, habe ich ja vorhin
gezeigt, Blazor von Microsoft
quasi eine
.NET-Umgebung für den Browser.
Also du kannst mit Blazor
.NET-Programme
im Browser laufen lassen,
kleinzeitig über
WebAssembly.
Also das ist so der zweite Trend, den ich anerkannt habe.
Nextcloud schon zu Ende.
Knärbär, überleg mal.
Ich bin 56 Minuten on.
Gab es schon mal irgendeinen Stream, wo ich in den
ersten 56 Minuten überhaupt schon mal
richtig angefangen habe mit dem Thema?
Ganz gute Übersicht für Web-Entwicklung.
Ach, das kenne ich.
Das kenne ich, aber das ist wirklich
ein guter Link,
den der True Elmo gepostet hat.
Es gibt ein paar so Sachen, es gibt auch so ein paar
Linksammlungen, die nennen sich dann
meistens Awesome, Blablabla,
Web-Development, Awesome, irgendwie
.NET Core und so was.
Ähm
Da haben Leute dann so ein paar
Sachen zusammengefasst.
In dem Fall geht es hier wahrscheinlich
um, ne das ist doch was anderes, den kenne ich
doch nicht. Um was für Technologien,
man kennen sollte im Web, in der
Web-Entwicklung.
Sieht aber auch ziemlich brauchbar aus, ja.
Und zumal das Ding hat 84.000 Sterne
auf GitHub, das kann nicht so schlecht sein.
Ähm
Genau, das sind die zwei Sachen, die ich in
puncto Frontend sehe aktuell.
So als Trends.
Und ich bin mal wirklich
gespannt drauf, was da noch
WebAssembly-technisch kommt.
Also was für klassische Sachen wir demnächst
im Browser laufen haben.
Die Musik ist vorbei.
Wir könnten was anderes noch anmachen.
Egal, ich muss ja erstmal nicht vergessen,
was ich sagen wollte.
Dass da noch viel mehr klassische
Sachen in Browser
kommen über WebAssembly als
also die letzten Jahre. Weil die letzten Jahre
war im Endeffekt Web-Entwicklung
dadurch
immer wieder neu, was es halt für
JavaScript-Frameworks und Tools gab.
Und es vergeht
ja in der Web-Entwicklung
quasi kein Tag, wo nicht irgendein
Typ ein neues Web-Framework rausbringt.
Oder ein neues
NPM-Alternative oder ein neues
Tool-XY oder
einen neuen Mini-Fire oder
was weiß ich.
Also Web-Entwicklung, da ist
da ist er teufellos.
Und jeder ist der Meinung, er muss da irgendwelche
halbfertigen Tools auf GitHub veröffentlichen
und sagen, hier Jungs, guck mal da und
dann wird das ganze aufgegriffen auf
Hacker-News und Reddit und alle erzählen,
oh geil, neues Tool, super lightweight,
ganz toll, ganz schnell
und super, viel besser als der alte Crap.
Allerdings fehlen noch ein paar Features.
Dann werden die Features eingebaut und dann ist das neue
genauso scheiße wie das alte. Aber das ist,
das kommt in JavaScript relativ oft vor.
Und
wenn man auf GitHub guckt, JavaScript ist nicht ohne
Grund die meistverbreitete
Sprache auf, aktuell auf GitHub.
Allerdings,
wie gesagt, .NET kommt in den Browser
jetzt über WebAssembly
und
es gibt auch schon
einen Rust
Compiler für WebAssembly habe ich gesehen.
CC++ bestimmt
auch.
Allerdings das Schöne an Blazor ist,
das ist nicht einfach nur
.NET für den Browser,
das muss ich ja mal aufschreiben,
da könnten wir übrigens mal
einen Stream zu machen, Blazor.
Habe ich selbst noch nicht großartig ausprobiert.
Das Schöne an Blazor ist, es ist nicht nur ein komplettes
.NET quasi für den Browser,
sondern es ist ein komplettes
quasi Web-UI-Framework.
Also du kannst damit wirklich
Webseiten bauen.
Es ist noch nicht so
schnell wie
beispielsweise CSS, HTML,
JavaScript, ist irgendwie logisch.
Das ist ja noch relativ neu
und
das braucht bestimmt auch noch ein paar Optimierungen.
Es ist auch aktuell noch nicht so einfach
Webseiten zu manipulieren von
WebAssembly heraus, allerdings
ich denke mal, das wird sich in den nächsten Jahren schon
auch in die richtige Richtung entwickeln
und ich denke auch, dass das die Zukunft sein wird.
Was
Backend angeht,
eigentlich das, was am einfachsten ist.
Also der Trend
bei Web-Anwendungen
geht eindeutig dahin, dass man
oder schon die letzten
Jahre oder die letzten fünf Jahre,
zehn Jahre fast schon, geht dahin, dass man
auf dem Server selbst
eigentlich kein HTML mehr macht.
Also kein HTML rendert oder so,
sondern dass man
quasi nur ein paar API-Endpunkte hat,
die JSON-Zeugs raushauen
und den Rest
macht man hauptsächlich kleinseitig.
Ausnahmen bestätigen die Regel
und 100% davon
oder 100%
Backend, 100% Kleinseitig,
der realistische Weg liegt irgendwo
dazwischen, aber der Trend geht ganz klar
dahin, dass man das Backend
Logik machen lässt
und einen Endpunkt hat, der JSON raushaut
und alles, was Frontend
angeht, macht man auch in Frontend.
Das war ja lange Zeit nicht so. Lange Zeit hast du ja eben
in deinem
Server, in deinem Backend
für deine Web-Anwendung, hast du HTML
quasi aufbereitet
für den Client, dass er das dann anzeigen kann.
Das macht man heute eigentlich sehr selten
noch.
Was du da im Backend verwendest, ist
ganz ehrlich, nimm das, was am einfachsten
ist. Am verbreitetsten ist
eindeutig, wobei,
würde ich mal gar nicht sagen, dass das eindeutig ist,
zumindest wenn du
Leute suchst, kannst du auf jeden Fall nicht
verkehrt
oder wenn du was suchst, was verbreitet ist,
zum Lernen, kannst du mit Node
mit Node und
den üblichen
weiß nicht was in Node
so die üblichen
Server-Frameworks sind, Express oder sowas
ähm
kannst du auf jeden Fall nicht
nichts verkehrt machen.
ähm
auch noch
verbreitet seit EON ist PHP
kannst du eigentlich auch relativ wenig verkehrt machen,
auch wenn die meisten Web-Entwickler
sagen, oh PHP, aber mittlerweile
PHP ist gar nicht wild.
Also PHP ist nicht verkehrt.
Facebook läuft zum größten Teil mit PHP.
Weiß nicht,
das dürfte das einzige Positive an Facebook sein.
ähm
und ansonsten so die klassischen Sachen wie ASP.NET
und sowas ist natürlich auch angesagt.
ähm
Nimm im Backend einfach das,
was für deinen Zweck das einfachste ist.
Ich würde da gar keine große Glaubensfrage drum herum machen.
Und das einfachste
ist in der Regel das, was du am besten kannst.
Und wenn du was kleines
brauchst, hat es keinen Sinn, dass
du jetzt irgendwie ein riesen Web-Framework nimmst,
dann mach eine Python-Flask-Anwendung
oder sowas. Wenn du einfach nur auf drei
Urls fünf verschiedene
Textausgaben brauchst, dann nimm
irgendwas kleines.
So
viel zum Thema Web-Anwendungen.
Okay, JSP ist, weiß ich nicht wie aktuell
wie angesagt das noch ist. Ich habe
ehrlich gesagt lange
nichts mehr zum Thema Java und Web-Anwendungen
gehört. Aber Java ist so
ein Ding, das wird immer verwendet.
Ohne, dass
groß drüber geredet wird.
Warum benutzt du Scoop und nicht
Choco? Das ist eine gute Frage, weil Scoop
rein userbasiert
ist. Also der
saut nur in meinem Heimatverzeichnis rum und nicht
systemweit.
Und ist für Developer
Software eigentlich am besten. Die haben alles
drin.
Excel.
Der Salami-Prinz ist
unser Excel-Programmer.
Salami-Prinz erinnert
mich ein bisschen an HerrTutorial.
Ist Nextcloud auf
deinem Pi? Glaube mal nein, weil du
das nicht gut verschlüsseln kannst.
Ne, aktuell ist Nextcloud bei mir auf der 4
HE-Kiste noch drauf, aber das soll ja darunter.
Und ich bin, ich bin eigentlich überhaupt
nicht zufrieden mit Nextcloud.
Deswegen wollte ich mir heute mal die neueste
Nextcloud-Version angucken.
Und mal schauen, ob das
noch, ob das mir jetzt besser
gefällt.
Das Geld kann ich nicht, ne.
Ich weiß was es ist, es ist eine funktionale
Programmiersprache,
aber kann
ich nicht. Das ist die einzige funktionale
Programmiersprache, wo ich ein bisschen,
ein bisschen, aber wirklich nur ein ganz kleines
bisschen was drin gemacht habe, ist F-Sharp bisher.
Das ist aber so wenig, dass ich noch nicht mal in
meiner Liste hier aufnehmen würde.
Ähm, das ist eine Frage,
die kommt auch öfters.
Vielleicht können wir da auch ein Kommando draus machen.
In welcher Programmiersprache hast du angefangen?
Also,
das erste Mal
in Kontakt so richtig
damit gekommen bin ich mit, mit
C, allerdings
fand ich das damals scheiße.
Deswegen empfehle ich auch keine mit C anzufangen.
Es war nur so eine Sache von der Schule
und wahrscheinlich war das ein ehemaliger Mathelehrer,
der halt nur ein bisschen C konnte.
Es war für den Arsch, ne.
Da habe ich auch nichts gelernt und da konnte ich auch nichts.
Danach.
Das ist nämlich das Problem,
wenn man mit Sprachen anfängt,
die für Einsteiger eben
zu große Hürden haben
oder zu abstrakt sind oder zu
low level sind oder zu zu wenig
ähm, bling bling
für Einsteiger haben, haben die danach
keinen Bock mehr. Ähm,
so richtig angefangen habe ich dann,
ich habe mir irgendwann mal ein Python-Buch geholt
und, ähm,
hab da ein bisschen mit rumgebastelt
und wusste dann allerdings nicht so recht.
Mir hat es super Spaß gemacht, was zu programmieren,
allerdings wusste ich nicht so recht,
was damit anfangen soll.
Und da bin ich dann auf die Idee gekommen,
ich würde mal gerne ein paar Windows-Desktop-Anwendungen machen.
Na, weil mich interessiert hat, wie funktioniert das überhaupt?
Wie macht man hier sowas da?
Und dann
habe ich mir einfach damals Visual Studio
runtergeladen und das kostenlose
Csharp.net Galileo
Open Book, was es übrigens heute noch gibt
und eine super Sache ist, wenn man mit Csharp anfangen will,
ähm, gibt es in der letzten Ausgabe
immer noch kostenlos bei Open Press
und seitdem, muss ich sagen,
das war zu .NET
2 Zeiten.
Da war .NET 2 gerade
relativ neu, mit Generics
und sowas. Ähm,
das ist schon ein bisschen her.
Wann war
.NET 2 Release?
Mal gucken,
kann ich dir sagen.
Okay, Visual Studio 2005.
Also
so ungefähr 2005, 2006
war das. Ist also schon ein bisschen
her. Und ich muss sagen,
seitdem,
seitdem ist .NET
eigentlich, obwohl ich ja eigentlich überhaupt kein
Microsoft-Fan bin in dem
Sinne, ähm,
ist .NET meine Lieblings-
Plattform geblieben und Csharp.
Wie gesagt,
ich programmier auch gerne was in
Ruby und sonst was, allerdings
insgesamt würde ich sagen, seit Anfang an
ist eigentlich, und das sagt schon viel
über so ein Framework in der Sprache aus,
dass sie hier einiges richtig gemacht haben müssen,
meine, meine Lieblingssprache geblieben.
Bist du alt?
Ja, ich bin nächsten Monat 35, ja.
So.
Cobol
Programmierer-Jobs.
Ja, endlich, da hab ich
schon drauf gewartet, ey.
Okay, ähm,
Leute, wollen wir noch ein paar
Stellenanzeigen roasten?
Oder wollen wir mit
Nextcloud anfangen?
Posten.
Wir machen aber nicht
viele, ne? Ich hab mir gedacht, das ist
noch was, was man immer mal zwischendurch im Stream machen
kann, ähm, immer dann,
wenn, wenn man sich
bisschen ausruhen muss.
So, nach dem Motto, ah, jetzt haben wir was gemacht, jetzt haben wir ein bisschen,
bisschen viel geschwätzt, bisschen, äh,
war zu anstrengend, jetzt können wir uns ein paar
Stellenanzeigen angucken.
Nextcloud machen wir, das geht ja nicht 20 Minuten
oder so.
Ne, Düsseldorf ist ein bisschen weit weg.
Also nach Köln, wobei,
kommt drauf an, also kommt drauf an, wie die Anwendung ist,
nach Köln brauch ich ne Stunde ungefähr,
reine Fahrzeit
vom Hauptbahnhof.
Also wird's wahrscheinlich nach
Düsseldorf, also
wird's wahrscheinlich, werde ich da unter eineinhalb Stunden
nicht über, nicht unterwegs sein. Das müsste sich dann aber
wirklich richtig lohnen,
dass ich jeden Tag eineinhalb Stunden fahren würde.
Und wahrscheinlich
mit der Bahn eher zwei Stunden, je nachdem, wo
das ist, wo das liegt.
Okay, wir fangen mal an
mit der, mit der Sache, wo ich
die lustigsten Jobanzeigen immer finde.
Und das ist meistens GoLab
Jobs. Ich weiß nicht, ob
bei GoLab Jobs nur komische Firmen
inserieren oder so,
aber da finde ich irgendwie immer die
lustigsten Sachen.
Autofahren kommt bei mir eh nicht in Frage.
Ich will da mit öffentlichen Verkehrsmitteln
hinkommen.
Also nicht in Frage würde ich nicht sagen, also
wenn das natürlich so was super geiles ist,
ja. Okay, ähm,
60329,
das ist Frankfurt. Und wir suchen jetzt mal,
wir suchen mal DevOps, so voll, voll
modern. Okay,
was haben wir denn hier?
DevOps Engineer. Weiß, männlich,
deutsch. Das passt doch.
Oh je, wenn das einer klippt,
dann ist, oh je,
dann sind die Feministen am Start.
Nein, das ist natürlich
weiblich, männlich, divers, ja.
Also ich sage das so immer gerne,
um die Leute ein bisschen zu triggern.
Weiß, männlich, deutsch.
Habe ich jetzt die ersten ein paar
aufgemacht? Das da, das da, das da.
Der D-Nig, der D-Nig sucht immer noch
Leute.
Das war einer, das war einer der
drei, die letztes Jahr,
ähm, wo jemand geschrieben hat,
dass die Leute suchen.
Wieso immer noch?
Ich wollte mich da echt bewerben, ne?
Also ich wollte mich, ich wollte mich ernsthaft
beim D-Nig bewerben. Habe ich aber, ihr wisst,
ich bin übelst faul, ähm.
Oh, Vodafone, oh Gott.
Okay, ähm,
gucken wir mal, was haben wir denn so?
gut, das, die,
die, man muss sich überlegen, die meisten
Stellenanzeigen sind von irgendwelchen, ähm,
ähm,
Human Resources-Typen gebastelt, ja.
Also sprich, von irgendwelchen
Personalabteilungsleuten oder
Recruiting-Typen, die halt von dem,
was in der Stellenbeschreibung gefordert wird,
keine Ahnung haben, ja.
Wenn man Glück hat, fragen sie diejenigen,
die Ahnung haben, ansonsten kommt was ganz
merkwürdiges bei raus.
Hast du gefragt, ob du über das Gehalt
reden darfst? Oh,
du hast mich gefragt auf der Arbeit.
Naja, also, nachdem ihr nicht wisst, wo ich
arbeite, ist das wahrscheinlich kein Problem.
Aber ich weiß nicht, ob ich das großartig erzählen will.
Denik
wär bestimmt geiler Arbeitgeber.
Ähm, ach, Moment,
nicht, beim Dezix, sorry,
Leute, beim Dezix wollte ich mich
bewerben, nicht bei der Denik.
Jetzt hab ich, jetzt hab ich durcheinander
geschmissen. Beides ja, nicht weit.
Beim Dezix
wollte ich mich bewerben.
Jetzt hab ich's durcheinander geschmissen.
Okay, gucken wir uns das mal an.
Also, ähm,
das schreiben alle
rein,
dass sie, dass sie, es gibt
kaum, kaum ne, ne
Webseite von irgendwelchen
Unternehmen, wo nicht
draufsteht, dass
sie in irgendwas der führende
Anbieter sind.
Die Frage ist viel eher,
was interessiert mich das in der Stelle, ist das irgendwie
wichtig für mich?
Egal, ähm,
vom Material,
mit mehr als 30.000, höchste Effizienz,
Bausteuerung von Logistik,
ihre Marken, Linde, Materialhandling,
Fan, Fan,
Vic, den hab ich noch nie gehört,
aber kann sein, ich kenn mich auch in,
in der Branche
nicht aus, zu, in welcher Branche sind die denn,
was, wozu gehört das denn?
Materialhandlinglösung, okay.
Kann ich mir überhaupt nichts
darunter vorstellen, wenn ich ehrlich bin,
was Materialhandlinglösungen sind.
Ähm,
als technisches Herz des Konzerns,
ja,
okay,
denn Digitalisierung gehört bei uns, unsere Mitarbeiter
kombinieren technologische Expertise
mit Geschäftssinn.
Oh, da bin ich der Falsche für.
Also wenn ich die Auswahl hab,
zwischen, ich mach's
zum Cash-Krabben,
oder
ich mach's technisch ausgefeilt,
dann mach ich's eher technisch ausgefeilt,
als zum Kohlekrabben.
Aus diesem Grunde wollen wir Experten, die
dynamically programmed sind.
Was auch immer das genau heißen mag.
Was,
jetzt, was stellt ihr euch da drunter
vor? Also, also mal angenommen,
ich würd das jetzt hier nicht im Stream lesen, sondern ich würd jetzt
wirklich suchen, so nach dem
Motto, ich hab jetzt, hab jetzt, keine Ahnung,
mal ganz billig gesagt, man hätte jetzt seine Ausbildung fertig
und sucht was, oder, oder, keine Ahnung,
man hat gekündigt, man wurde gekickt, was auch immer,
und man sucht was. Man liest
das jetzt. Also, das heißt, man muss sich wirklich
damit beschäftigen. Was könnte
dynamically programmed gemeint
sein? Leute, die besonders flexibel
sind? Leute,
die, Leute, wollen die uns sagen,
Leute, die besonders flexibel sind, vielleicht?
Also sprich, die auf Überstunden
arbeiten, und, äh,
egal, kommen wir mal weiter. Das ist ja eigentlich das Interessante.
Ihre Aufgaben.
Als DevOps-Engineer
ähm,
sind Sie für die Automatisierung der
Build, Release, Deployment und Testprozesse verantwortlich.
Das würde ja von der Stellenbeschreibung
her ziemlich gut
auf das zutreffen, was ich aktuell mache.
Das würde,
das würde gut passen, ja.
Ähm,
Sie entwickeln und verbessern Monitoring-
Lösungen. Kann ich auch machen?
Würde ich auch gern machen.
Finde ich okay.
Sie betreuen als Teil des Teams unsere
Anwendungen. Na gut.
Ich mein,
ich betreue als Teil des Teams unsere Anwendungen.
Ich weiß nicht, ich betreue nicht die Anwendungen, sondern ich bin Teil
eines Teams, der die Anwendungen betreut.
Und da ist man natürlich als DevOps
schon der Richtige, ja.
Sie sind verantwortlich für die Optimierung der Continuous
Integration und Continuous Delivery
Pipeline. Pipeline auf Basis
von Cloud- und Containertechnologie.
Also, ich muss sagen, die Aufgaben
klingen
ganz klassisch nach sowas hier, ja.
Also, klassisch. Von klassisch kann man in dem Fall nicht
sprechen. Ist ja nicht so, dass
das ja schon so super lang gibt. Ähm,
aber zumindest die Aufgaben
passen schon mal zu dem, was sie
suchen. Das finde ich schon mal gut.
Das ist bei den meisten Stellenanzeigen
nicht so.
Bei den meisten Stellenanzeigen suchen sie eigentlich
drei Leute und schreiben nur einen Titel
oben hin. Okay, ihr Profil.
Sie verfügen über eine abgeschlossene Ausbildung oder
über eine abgeschlossene Hochschule. Ja.
Sie
bringen Erfahrung in der Automatisierung
von Prozessen für die Entwicklung nach dem Prinzip
von Kinesin. Ja.
Sie sind vertraut im Umgang mit
Automatisierung, DevOps, Automatisierungs-Tool,
Docker, Ansible, Jenkins. Ja.
Also, mit allem.
Ähm,
sie haben Erfahrung in agilen
Methoden wie beispielsweise Scrum.
Ja, wenn man es richtig, die Frage ist,
das ist so ein Ding, das ist so ein
Scrum schreiben sie alle gerne immer hin.
Ähm,
auf ihre, weil
alle, es sagen heute alle, sie sind
agil. Es ist heute
überhaupt nicht mehr angesagt, wenn man
nicht agil ist, ja. Also jeder
sagt, sie sind agil. Ähm,
man sieht aber
relativ selten, dass das auch wirklich,
wirklich gemacht wird. Also,
es gibt genug,
genug Läden, und da war ich mal
bei einem,
ähm, die verstehen unter
Scrum, wir stellen uns
einmal am Tag
für eine Viertelstunde
in einen Raum und jeder sagt,
was er gerade macht. Und man darf
nicht sitzen.
Das ist zwar ein bisschen
Teil von der ganzen Geschichte,
allerdings bei weitem ist es nicht der Kern
dessen, ja. Und ansonsten
macht man einfach alles ganz normal.
Das ist nicht Scrum. Das ist, wir
sagen, wir machen das, ohne dass wir es machen.
Ja, also für mich,
für mich ist agil eigentlich, dass es
um,
um die Leute im Team
geht, dass es um die Ideen der
Leute im Team geht, dass es um die Kommunikation
der Leute in, in,
in dem Team untereinander geht,
dass es kurze
Abstände gibt, ähm,
also, dass man nicht
sagt, okay, wir entwickeln jetzt ein
halbes Jahr was hinter verschlossenen Türen,
dass es kurze Abstände gibt,
dass es kurze Sprints, wie es das immer dann gibt,
äh, wo dann geguckt wird, okay, was brauchen wir
noch, was machen wir noch,
dass das halt alles ein bisschen,
wie nennt man das so schön,
continuous
ist, ja.
Genau. User Stories, sowas in der
Richtung, ja. User Stories ist auch so
ein Ding, das kann man komplett in die, in die, in die, in die
Tonne treten, wenn man's nicht richtig macht.
Ne User Story ist, zum Beispiel,
ähm, also ist, wenn man sich,
wenn man sich quasi in die
Rolle desjenigen reinversetzt,
der das dann benutzen will. So nach dem
Motto, ich als Support
Mitarbeiter möchte
schnell alle Kundendaten
finden. So, so, ganz
kurz, klar. Das wär ne User Story
zum Beispiel. Ja, und das kann man
sich dann als Thema nehmen, oder
davon gibt's mehrere User Stories, man kann's dann auch
so machen, dass man, ähm,
sich überlegt,
auf welche User Stories verteilen
wir jetzt irgendwie die Leute, oder man kann sogar die Leute das
selbst irgendwie bestimmen lassen, was,
was sie für wichtig halten, weil, wie gesagt, beim,
für mich geht's bei diesen ganzen agilen Sachen
eigentlich um die Leute in dem Team
drinne.
Dass die sich kreativ daran beteiligen können,
an der ganzen Sache.
Im Gegensatz zu herkömmlichen Planungs
Methoden.
Ja, okay, ähm,
Sie haben idealerweise bereits Erflachung mit der
Azure Cloud. Hab ich auch! Das ist ja,
fast wie gemacht für mich, äh.
Sie kommunizieren im internationalen
Umfeld deutsch und englisch sicher.
We are all sitting in one
boat.
Krieg ich auch gebacken, wenn's sein muss.
Wir bieten ein Börsenradar
mit erstklassigen Meinungen. Jetzt, jetzt
bin ich mal gespannt. Was, was, was,
was gibt's denn Tolles?
Timbo,
das ist echt ne Frage, ja.
Ähm, er
schreibt, ich würde gerne wissen, wie die User Stories bei
DICE und ACTION aussehen. Die User Stories bei
DICE und ACTIVISION sehen aus, ich als
User habe zu wenig Skins zu kaufen.
Wann gibt es neue?
So in der Richtung.
Äh, ein börsennotiertes Unternehmen mit erstklassigen
Meinungen. Ganz ehrlich,
das schreiben viele in die, in die,
in diese Sache. Wir bieten.
Das finde ich ehrlich gesagt
vollkommen wurscht.
Das hat, das sagt für meinen, für meinen Job
da überhaupt nichts aus.
Umfassende Einarbeitung in den
Aufgabenbereich. Das würde ich ja mal,
das würde ich nicht unter wir bieten schreiben.
Umfassende Einarbeitung in ihren Aufgabenbereich,
das ist,
das ist schon unter basic
eigentlich. Ich meine,
erwartet wirklich
jemand, dass man sich irgendwo hinsetzt und ohne Einarbeitung
man automatisch weiß,
ähm, was man machen soll?
Das ergibt eigentlich keinen Sinn, oder?
Äh, spannende Aufgaben
und ein kollegiales Miteinander.
Ich würde mal hoffen, dass kein
Spasten dabei sind, um es jetzt mal so zu sagen.
Wir hatten schon, wir hatten bei uns auf der Arbeit
und da, wo ich vorher war, auch schon genug
Deppen, ja. Also,
ich, ich würde mal hoffen,
dass die meisten Läden heute mittlerweile
Wert darauf legen, dass die Leute
jetzt sozial
nicht ganz
unbrauchbar sind. Ich meine, ihr wisst, ich mag keine
Menschen, das habe ich schon oft genug gesagt, ja.
Ähm,
aber ich komme mit Leuten aus. Vor allem, wenn sie mich nicht
nerven und mir nicht auf den Keks gehen mit irgendwas.
Und, und auf diesem Niveau,
sollte das eigentlich jeder hinkriegen.
Attraktive Vergütung sowie zusätzliche
Sozialleistungen.
Also, wenn es eine betriebliche
Altersvorsorge gäbe oder, oder Berufsunfähigkeit
oder sowas, dann würde das wahrscheinlich drinnen
stehen, denke ich mal.
Wahrscheinlich sind die zusätzlichen sozialen Leistungen
nur das, was sie, äh, gesetzlich
ähm, machen
müssen.
Attraktive Vergütung sagt
nichts aus, sagt
jeder. Sagt nix.
Also, im Prinzip sind alle vier Punkte
unter, wir bieten, komplett für die hohle Hand.
Das, sie, also im Prinzip bieten sie nichts.
Wenn man so will. Laut dieser
Stellenanzeige.
Betriebliche Renten sind Mr. Riester.
Das kommt drauf an. Wenn du ne
betriebliche Altersvorsorge, ich hab das ja auch gemacht.
Und zwar aus einem Grund,
weil, ähm, nicht nur du einen
bezahlst, sondern der, fast,
fast nochmal das gleiche vom Arbeitgeber
mit einem bezahlt wird. Und ich war damals
extra bei nem Beratungstyp,
weil ich von sowas ja keine Ahnung hab.
Ich war damals extra bei nem Beratungstyp,
bei nem Honorarberatungstyp wohlgemerkt,
nicht bei einem, der mir was aufschwärzen will.
Und hab ihm das, den Vertrag
gezeigt und die Sache, was die anbieten.
Und bei mir hat er gesagt, das lohnt sich in dem Fall auf jeden Fall.
Deswegen hab ich das gemacht.
Allerdings ist es
bei mir jetzt abgelaufen, das heißt, ähm,
das war ja auch der Grund, warum ich die letzten Jahre immer gesagt
hab, ey, äh,
ich bin jetzt da erstmal auf unbestimmte Zeit
gebunden dran.
Aber wie gesagt, sei
Januar diesen Jahres ist das nicht mehr
so. Jetzt könnte ich wieder.
Wenn ich denn wollen würde.
Ähm,
Sie wollen in einem agilen Umfeld gemeinsam
mit internationalen Teams exzellente IT-Services
liefern. Ehrlich gesagt, wenn die mich fragen
würden, was ich, was ich, was ich will,
das heißt, ich will erstmal ordentlich
Geld haben.
Das ist eigentlich so die grundsätzliche
Sache.
Ich geh ja nicht hin, um
irgendwie
die Welt besser zu machen oder
ähm,
na, ich geh da erstmal hin, um was ordentliches
zu verdienen. Und natürlich,
das in Kombination
mit, dass die Arbeit auch was, äh,
auch Spaß macht und interessante
Themen hat und so. Klar, das bevorzugt
ja jeder. Aber,
also, wenn sie mich fragen,
was ich will, dann ist erstmal ein ordentliches Gehalt
Interesse
geweckt. Also,
ich muss ehrlich gesagt sagen,
also, mit
diesem Wir bieten haben sie mein Interesse nicht geweckt.
Auch, wenn das hier
fast 1 zu 1
wie die Faust aufs Auge
zu dem passen würde, was
ich mache, wo ich Erfahrung drin hab,
wo ich, wo ich über 10 Jahre Erfahrung
drin hab,
was ich alles kann
und was, also,
vom Profil her
zu 95% auf mich passen
würde, würde ich jetzt sagen, also,
also,
das Wir bieten hat mich jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig
überzeugt.
Interesse geweckt, nope.
Alter, was ist denn das für eine Mail?
Dynamically programmed.
Vielleicht guck ich mir die irgendwann nochmal an.
So, was haben wir denn als nächstes?
Also, das Wir bieten
war irgendwann wirklich nicht so überzeugt.
Ach so, stimmt. Statt da eigentlich, was die suchen?
Also, ich meine, die suchen, die suchen ja wohl offensichtlich
einen intern, sonst würden sie das hier nicht reinschreiben.
Aber da steht auch nichts von
Projekten oder so drin. Also, sie suchen nur wirklich
jemand, der da langfristig bleibt.
Okay,
als nächstes, was haben wir jetzt?
Define. Analytisch,
technologisch,
quantitativ.
Also, ist das quasi,
quasi, äh,
mehr Masse statt Klasse, oder?
Was ist
man, wenn man quantitativ ist?
Quantitativ.
Der Menge.
Anzahl. Ist man dann sick?
Im
großen Stil. Oh, das ist eine schöne Übersetzung
davon, ja. Ähm.
Seine Tageslaufzeit unbefristet.
Einsatz aus Deutschland, Frankfurt oder Main?
Zum nächstmöglichsten Zeitpunkt.
Nächstmöglichster Zeitpunkt?
Muss ich mal überlegen, keine Ahnung.
Was wäre denn das bei mir? Ich glaube,
drei Monate?
Ich glaube,
ich habe drei Monate.
Ach, keine Ahnung. Oder zwei Monate? Ich weiß es gar nicht.
Ähm.
Define ist ein
führendes, europäisches Beratungsunternehmen mit
Standort in Berlin. Blablabla.
Das schreibt...
Da kommt bestimmt jetzt auch wieder, dass sie führend in
irgendeinem Bereich sind, oder so.
Mit über 800 qualifizierten
Beratern unterstützen wir unsere Kunden
Bankenversicherungen. Gut, wir sind in Frankfurt.
Also,
natürlich Bankenversicherung, Industrie oder
was sonst. Bei anspruchsvollen
quantitativen
proze...
prozessualen
und technologischen
Anforderungen.
Das schreit so ein bisschen
eitel, oder?
Äh.
Strategieberatung, Fachberatung,
Technologieberatung ist alles
in einem.
Hm.
Äh. Der technische Support unserer Mitarbeiter
wird von einem internen Abteiabteilenden
durchgeführt.
Suchen die Supportleute?
Äh. Die fallen weg.
Und um
den hohen Qualitätsanspruch von
Beratern und internen Mitarbeitern
unser Team auch weiterhin zu erfüllen, suchen wir für unseren Hauptsitz
in Frankfurt am Main zum nächstmöglichen
Zeitpunkt einen DevOps-Engineer in Vollzeit.
Ok. Also, was soll man machen? Aufgaben.
Verantwortung
für die Installation, Betrieb, Troubleshooting
von System...
Das ist entweder ein Server-Admin
oder ein Support-Mitarbeiter?
Ich glaube
nicht, dass sie einen DevOps-Engineer suchen.
Ok. Ähm.
Administration unterschiedlicher Server unter darauf installierten
Applikationen...
Entwicklung von
Lösungsansätzen und Durchführung interner
Projekte?
Optimierung der IT-Struktur
und entsprechender Arbeit... Moment!
Was genau suchen die?
Das ist, das ist so eine typische
Anzeige, die eigentlich drei
Leute in einem suchen.
Die suchenden Support-Mitarbeiter,
die suchenden Server-Admin,
die suchenden Projektmanager
und die suchen, ähm,
einen Organisatortyp, so einen
Organisator-ITIL-Mensch.
Also eigentlich suchen die vier Sachen.
Die suchen, die suchen, eigentlich suchen die vier Stellen.
Und ich mein, ja,
DevOps ist
von mehreren Bereichen etwas,
allerdings geht's nicht darum,
dass man vier Personen in einem ist.
Also, das ergibt überhaupt
keinen Sinn.
Also das ist schon so eine komplett rote Karte,
wenn du in der Überschrift siehst, was sie suchen
und in den Aufgaben sich das erstens
mit der Stellenbeschreibung, also mit dem,
mit dem, mit der Position
nicht deckt
und die Aufgaben auch
miteinander nichts zu tun haben. Wie gesagt,
ähm,
das hier ist eher so eine Support-Geschichte,
das ist eine Server-Admin-Geschichte,
das ist eine,
eigentlich so, das beides,
das ist so eine, so eine Projektmanagement-
ITIL-Geschichte.
Also, naja, ähm,
Anforderung, abgeschlossenes
Studium oder Ausbildung in der Bereich ITIL,
Know-How in der
Administration der gängigen Server-Betriebssysteme.
Was sind denn die gängigen
Server-Betriebssysteme bei euch?
Das ist, also,
das ist eine Anzeige, die hat jemand von
der Personalabteilung geschrieben, der keine Ahnung hat,
was die eigentlich wollen.
Das ist 100 pro sowas.
Die wissen, also derjenige, der die Anzeige
geschrieben hat, weiß nicht, was, was sie eigentlich
haben wollen. Dem haben sie
bloß gesagt, wir brauchen jemand, der das und das kann,
und da haben sie so eine, so eine, so eine
Anzeige draus gestrickt.
Ich mein, gängigen Server-Betriebssysteme,
das hört sich erstmal simpel an,
ja, ist es aber vor allem im
Umfeld wie Banken und sowas gar nicht.
Das kann IBM Mainframe sein,
das, also, um jetzt mal mit exotischen Sachen anzufangen,
ja, das könnte IBM Mainframe Host gedöhnt
sein, das könnte noch uralt,
ja, IEX zum Beispiel
oder sonst was sein,
und das könnte natürlich auch Windows und Linux sein.
Allerdings,
du wirst keinen
finden, der alle vier Sachen gut kann.
Und ich mein, so ein
Host administriert sich auch ein bissl anders als
ein Linux oder nochmal anders als
ein Windows oder so ein olles IEX.
Und
Virtualisierungsumgebung. Gibt's auch mehrere
Sachen. Ist es Microsoft? Ist es, ist es
VMware? Wahrscheinlich ist es VMware, weil
VMware im Business-Bereich so das verbreitet ist, aber
man, man weiß es nicht. Was mich wieder
zu dem Schluss bringt, dass, dass irgendein
Personalabteilungstyp geschrieben hat oder
Personalabteilungsfrau geschrieben hat,
ähm,
oder Personalabteilungsdivers geschrieben hat,
der keine Ahnung hat, was
die eigentlich haben wollen.
Kenntnisse im Umgang mit der Microsoft-basierten
IT-Infrastruktur, insbesondere
Exchange und Active Directory.
Oh!
Das, das
nix für mich.
IKIT! Es wird ja immer schlimmer!
Ach du Scheiße!
Idealerweise verfügen sie über Datenbank
und oder Scripting-Kenntnisse sowie
Erfahrungen der Anbieter von SharePoint und Skype
for Business!
Monka Giga!
Wartet Leute!
Ich muss mich erschießen!
Also eine Sache,
da müsste ich schon
kurz vorm Verhungern sein,
dass ich Skype for Business
Administrator werden würde.
Oder aber,
oder aber,
die geben mir 150k im Jahr.
Wobei,
selbst dafür würde ich
es mir nochmal überlegen.
Die geben mir 200k im Jahr.
Dann, dann würde ich auch Skype
for Business administrieren.
Dann würde ich jetzt komplett loyo,
wäre mir das komplett egal.
Dann würde ich mich da 8 Stunden hinsetzen,
Skype for Business machen und
mit Kohle wieder heimgehen und sagen,
draufgeschissen.
Praktische Erfahrungen in der Administration und oder
Anwendungsbetreuung sowie entsprechende
Zusatzqualifikationen sind von vorn.
Moin!
Praktische Erfahrungen in der Administration.
Also ich würde mal sagen,
jemand, der,
wie passt das denn zusammen?
Das ist,
das ist zwingend
erforderlich, praktische Erfahrungen in der Administration.
Wie sollst du das denn sonst machen?
Strukturierte, eigenständige,
gut das schreiben sie alle. Motivation zur Weiterentwicklung.
Also bisher fand ich die erste
Stellenanzeige richtig gut,
die hier nicht.
Strukturierte, eigenständige Service.
Motivation zur Weiterentwicklung
der eigenen Kenntnisse und Qualifikation.
Wird schwierig, wenn man quasi Mann für alles ist.
Motivation zur Weiterentwicklung.
Also es heißt im Prinzip,
es gibt keine Schulung,
es erklärt dir keiner was und
du sollst dich nicht so anstellen,
wenn es ein Bereich ist, von dem du eigentlich keine Ahnung hast,
sondern einfach mal machen.
Fähigkeit komplexe Sachverhalte verständlich zu formulieren.
Okay, wir bieten.
Da müssen sie jetzt mal richtig reinhauen,
was sie bieten, weil
was da oben ist, ist nur wirklich nicht überzeugend.
Einen modernen Arbeitsplatz
im Herzen von Frankfurt.
Im Herzen von Frankfurt
ist das einzige, was für mich relevant ist.
Dass es ein moderner Arbeitsplatz ist, würde ich jetzt mal
eigentlich von ausgehen.
Einen abwechslungsreichen, verantwortlich
Okay, Standard,
Standard Floskel.
Flache Hierarchien, auch Standard,
was viele immer so schreiben.
Flache Hierarchien sind übrigens oftmals gar nicht so
flach, wie sie glauben, dass sie sind.
Das ist so ein bisschen,
wie es manche Firmen gibt,
die sagen so nach dem Motto,
ja, bei uns darf jeder zu jedem Thema was sagen.
Ja,
bis auf ein paar, die mehr sagen dürfen.
Also, es ist unrealistisch, davon auszugehen,
dass das,
dass die meisten Firmen so flach
sind, wie sie sich immer, wie sie immer tun.
Das ist aber
auch jetzt nix,
was man wirklich bietet.
So bietet, wer zum Beispiel,
wenn einer sagt, hey, bei uns gibt es,
da gibt es mittags kostenlos Eis.
Was ganz bescheuertes zu sagen,
aber das wäre was, wo ich sagen würde, ey,
das ist schon mal nice, ja.
Das ist was, wo ich sagen würde, hey.
Auf der anderen Seite,
ganz ehrlich, wenn einer
ein ordentliches Gehalt bietet,
ist das
schon mal die beste
Grundlage dafür, dass das Ganze was wird.
Freiraum und Flexibilität
bei der persönlichen Arbeitsgestaltung,
das ist so ein Satz, wo ich mir,
wenn ich mir das in Gedanken machen würde,
das passt nämlich ein bisschen
zu der ganzen Sache hier oben,
dass eigentlich keiner so wirklich
dich wahrscheinlich
einarbeiten wird, dir sagen wird,
was du machst, dass quasi von dir
irgendwas erwartet wird und keiner
erklärt dir jemals so genau was.
So liest sich das für mich.
Das ist kein Pluspunkt.
Und unter Flexibilität verstehen
ja viele so nach dem Motto,
ich kann den Typ auch am Samstag,
wenn er gerade auf dem Klo ist,
am Kacken.
Oder hat bestimmt keine Probleme,
auch mal irgendwie nach München zu fahren
für drei Tage und da irgendwie was
einzubauen oder so.
Attraktive Sozialleistung,
30 Tage Jahresurlaub, als ist das jetzt
eine attraktive Sozialleistung,
das ist Standard.
Betriebliche Altersversorgung, okay,
das kann ganz gut sein.
Fahrtkosten,
das ist ganz nice.
Das ist wirklich
verkehrt.
Überstundenausgleich,
das müssen sie sogar machen.
Also,
es sei denn, man hat irgendeinen speziellen
Vertrag und ich glaube,
selbst da wurden jetzt erst letztens noch
ein bisschen engere Grenzen gesetzt.
Ansonsten ist das eigentlich Pflicht.
Wenn du einen Arbeitsvertrag hast,
da stehen 40 Stunden drin,
kann nicht einfach einer
sagen, ey, wir arbeiten 60 Stunden.
Individuell,
aktuelle Trainingsmöglichkeiten,
regelmäßiges Feedback.
Okay, kann alles damit gemeint sein.
Kann auch sein, wir gehen dir regelmäßig auf den Sack,
weil wir noch mehr von dir haben wollen.
Tolle Mitarbeiter-Events.
Okay, da hört es bei mir schon auf.
Tolle Mitarbeiter-Events sind
in der Regel nicht toll.
Ja, also, wem das jetzt gefallen hat,
kann sich an Frau Trollen wenden.
Nein, machen wir nicht.
Next.
Also, also, das war hier,
das war gar nichts.
Das war wirklich gar nichts.
Das war eher, das war so eine,
passt alles nicht zusammen.
Ich mein, mich juckt es ja manchmal
bei solchen Sachen, ja.
Aber das kannst du nicht machen.
Das kannst du nicht im Stream bringen.
Da irgendeine Mail hinzuschreiben mit
ein paar Nachfragen, das ist...
Sucht Max einen neuen Job?
Naja, ich bin offen für
neue Sachen seit 1.1.
2019, also seit Anfang des Jahres.
Also, wenn es was Tolles, Neues gibt,
ähm,
können wir uns da gerne
drüber austauschen,
ja.
Also, ich hab was.
Ich bin da auch nicht unzufrieden.
Sagen wir mal nicht großartig unzufrieden.
Es gibt immer ein paar Sachen, die nerven.
Ist überall so. Außerdem sieht das Glas überall
auch immer grüner aus.
Aber wenn es irgendwie was
in Frankfurt oder Umgebung, was
Neues gibt, was gut passt
und was mir gefällt, bin ich da sofort
dabei.
Ich hab mal in Ulm gearbeitet.
Wenn es darum geht,
die Leistungsfähigkeit...
Wie heißt die Firma?
Risk Consulting.
Okay.
Äh, wenn es darum geht,
die Leistungsfähigkeit von Unternehmen zu stärken,
macht uns niemand so schnell
was vor.
Als eines
der deutschlandweit führenden
Dienstleister, da haben wir es wieder,
das hat jeder irgendwie drinstehen.
Als eines der deutschlandweit
führenden Dienstleistungsunternehmen
im Cloud-Umfeld bieten wir renommierten
Kunden, darunter die
erfolgreichsten und namenhaftesten
Enterprise-Unternehmen.
Heißt Enterprise nicht Unternehmen?
Ist das...
Was heißt
Enterprise?
Heißt Unternehmen, weiß ich doch.
Egal, Consulting.
Eine breite
Palette von Services und Lösungen.
In den Bereichen
Consulting, Development
und Operations.
DevOps.
Achso.
Development und Operations.
Treiben wir die digitale
Transformation konsequent
voran. Unsere Verantwortung
reicht dabei von der strategischen
Beratung über die ganzheitliche
Konzeption und Realisierung von Projekten
bis hin zum Management der bestehenden
IT-Systemlandschaft.
Aha. Was uns für dich als Arbeitgeber
besonders macht, das Vertrauen in
unser Team.
Professionell sowie kollegial leistet
es viel, trägt Verantwortung und
beeinflusst wesentlich die Zukunft der
Risk.
Ich verstehe unter Risk was anderes als
ein Consulting-Unternehmen.
Aber das ist wahrscheinlich so eine IT.
Das ist auf jeden Fall mein Problem,
nicht den Ihres.
Die diskontieren aber auch die eigenen.
Jeder einzelne ist es wert, in ihn
zu investieren und wir
investieren in die Menschen.
Profitiere auch du,
von dieser Investition
in dich.
Sofern die Investition
so aussieht, okay.
Profitiere auch,
entwickle mit uns deine persönliche Zukunft
weiter nachhaltig individuell.
Das klingt jetzt zwar sehr 0815 formuliert,
vom Ansatz her finde ich das aber gar
nicht schlecht,
wenn das denn wirklich so ist und
nicht einfach nur
hohles Gelaber, das auch nochmal rauszustellen,
wenn es ihnen wirklich um die Leute geht.
Gibt ja tatsächlich Läden,
da sind die Leute nicht
da zum Wegschmeißen oder
die Leute nicht da, um irgendwas
zu machen und danach zu sagen, brauchen wir nicht mehr.
Sondern die haben wirklich vor,
mit den Leuten auch langfristig zu arbeiten.
Soll ja vorkommen.
Dann ist das auch gar nicht schlecht, wenn man das gleich reinschreibt.
Unbefristete Festanstellung
am Standort Köln oder
Frankfurt, Vollzeit, sofort.
Oh, die haben ja ganz schön viel Text hier.
Du bist für die Berufswelt bereit
und fühlst dich von dem
gestellten Aufgabenprofil herausgefordert.
Du kannst deiner entsprechenden
schulischen Bildung nach, bist höflich,
kommunikativ und willst dich zukunftsorientiert
aufstellen. Dann ergreife deine Möglichkeit,
den optimalen Einstieg in die IT von morgen zu sichern.
Wir bilden dich zum absoluten
Experten aus. Konsequent, individuell
und inklusive Zertifizierung.
Dein Wissen, bestimmt ist da auch eine ITIL-Zertifizierung
dabei.
Dein Wissen und deine fachliche
Kompetenz erweiterst du durch intensive
Trainings und
stetigen Wissensaustausch
in einem großen Team.
Okay, bla bla.
Was jetzt jetzt kommt.
Als DevOps-Engineer arbeitest du an spannenden
Fragestellungen, innovativen Projekten rund um
die Themen Deployment
und Operations. Ja, deswegen heißt das ja auch so.
Du verbesserst bestehende Prozesse
und entwickelst kontinuierlich an der Automatisierung,
im Datacenter und in der Cloud.
Okay.
Dann machen sie die möglichen Aufgabenbereiche nur
grob skizziert. Du gestaltest die Richtung.
Ja, es wäre schon nicht schlecht, wenn ihr wüsstet, was ihr genau sucht.
Ich glaube, das richtet sich eher an jemanden, der
gerade frisch mit seiner Ausbildung fertig ist.
Verbesserung von Konzepten und Lösungen im Bereich
von DevOps-Teams.
Okay. Integration und Weiterentwicklung
in DevOps-orientierten Tools.
Git, Puppet, Docker,
Kubernetes, Terraform.
Ja okay, das ist ja, also
das da ist ja zur Zeit übelst angesagt.
Das da auch.
Puppet ist
etabliert. Das ist ein Tool,
wo du Server quasi
automatisch reproduzierbar aufbauen kannst mit.
Und Git ist Standard.
Durchführung von Anforderungsanalysen
hinsichtlich der technischen Ausgestellung
und Umsetzung neuer Strategien.
Ich kann mich nicht
wirklich darunter vorstellen.
Ich würde schon
prinzipiell zu den Aufgaben von einem
DevOps-Engineer zählen, wenn jemand zu dir
kommt und fragt,
was sagst du dazu?
Oder wir haben hier was vor,
gibt man da einen Senf dazu?
Würde ich da schon dazu zählen.
Aufgaben und Bereitstellung von Cloud-Infrastruktur.
Wow, man baut ganze
Clouds auf. Nicht schlecht.
Alter, Chat, was ist los
mit euch?
Migration
klassische Infrastruktur
Begleitung der Entwicklung
neuer Anwendungen von der Idee bis zum operativen
Implementierung
Implementierung neuer Softwarelösung
innerhalb der Cloud. Teamarbeit
Agilität
Okay, das ist irgendwie ziemlich
nichtssagend. Könnte ganz gut sein,
man weiß es nicht so genau.
Also
Ich finde, es ist auch irgendwie ein bisschen
Resident-Sleeper geschrieben.
Also spricht mich jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig an.
Click for Benefits
Okay, gucken wir uns mal an, was
die für Vorteile haben.
Verpass deiner Karriere den richtigen Kick.
Jetzt heißen sie RIS,
hier oben hießen sie noch RISK.
Wie heißen sie denn jetzt? Ah, sie heißen
RIS und C ist wahrscheinlich für Consulting.
RIS Consulting.
Was sind dann die Vorteile?
Bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla
Benefits. Okay.
Flexible Arbeitszeiten.
Je nachdem,
wie sie es meinen, kann es auch
nicht unbedingt was Gutes sein.
Vertrauensarbeitszeiten.
Das kann auch was Gutes und was
Schlechtes sein. Bei den meisten würde ich sagen,
ist es eher was Schlechtes.
Das kann beides sein.
Also ich würde es aber eher
mal nicht unbedingt jetzt zu was Gutem zählen.
Generell,
wenn zu viel von Flexibilität
und Arbeitszeiten geschrieben wird, ist das
für mich kein allzu gutes Zeichen.
Also ich will schon
damit planen können, wenn ich sage,
ich arbeite 4 Tage die Woche,
3 Tage, 5 Tage, je nachdem,
oder sagen wir mal, ich arbeite
irgendwie 32 Stunden die Woche zum Beispiel,
dann will ich auch mich drauf verlassen
können, dass ich in der Regel
32 Stunden die Woche arbeite.
Sonst würde ich einen 40 Stunden Vertrag abschließen
oder einen 50 Stunden Vertrag,
welches ich regelmäßig machen muss.
Es sollte,
wenn man, das sollte die Arbeitszeit,
die im Vertrag drin steht, sollte
...
also nicht nur die Regel sein, sondern
wirklich die
95%-Regel sollte
das sein. Ansonsten, äh,
guck mal,
ich meine, es ist doch eigentlich total beknackt.
Also,
pfff,
es kann gut und schlecht sein,
ja, aber bei den meisten würde ich eher sagen,
es ist nichts Gutes, wenn schon gleich was von Flexibel
Arbeitszeiten drinsteht.
Homeoffice.
Das wiederum finde ich
gut.
Wenn Sie das gleich reinschreiben.
Unsere Regelung bietet
die Möglichkeit, auch flexibel von zu Hause,
je nach Status hat jeder mindestens 10
Homeoffice-Tage, 10 Homeoffice-Tage
im Kalender, ja.
10 Homeoffice, das ist doch
kein Pluspunkt, 10 Tage.
Im Jahr.
Hätten die gesagt, im Monat,
dann könnte man das da reinschreiben, aber,
ey, komm, Leute, im Jahr.
Im Jahr.
Also, wenn ich
10 Homeoffice-Tage im Jahr
Standard hab, dann würde ich nicht
Homeoffice bei mir überhaupt reinschreiben.
Wenn eben einer sagt,
10 Tage im Monat,
okay.
Dann mach ich meine Homeoffice-Tage im Jahr
und bei mir stand nirgends sowas von großartig
Homeoffice drinne.
Hast du Shortcuts für dein E-Board?
Ja, Steuerung L ist 0, zum Beispiel.
Steuerung M ist MonkaS.
Und Steuerung 3 ist 0, 3D.
Und Steuerung G
ist, nee, ach, weiß ich nicht mehr.
Ja, aber es kann auch Shortcuts.
Urlaub.
Das,
also, ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob sie,
was wirklich die Pflicht ist,
aber es sind gesetzlich vorgeschrieben,
sind entweder 26 oder 30
Tage, eins von beidem.
Ah, 24.
20, nein, das sind auf jeden Fall mehr als
20 Tage. Zumindest
ist 30 Tage jetzt
Standard, eigentlich.
Das ist jetzt nix,
außergewöhnliches.
Ist bei uns auch so.
Urlaubsanträge werden in der
Regel immer zügig für den beantragten
Zeitpunkt genehmigt. Also, dass Urlaubsanträge
in einem normalen Rahmen
genehmigt werden, das sollte selbstverständlich sein.
Sonderurlaub, Bildungsurlaub und
Sabbaticals sind üblich, doch entsprechend
abzustimmen. Gut, das ist jetzt auch nix Tolles.
Work-Life-Balance, die Vereinbarkeit von Beruf
und Piratenstelle, insbesondere im Projekt, blablabla.
Um diese Herausforderung gehen
wir auf ein Bedürfnis.
Egal, ob ein Projekteinsatz am
Wohnort gewünscht
ist.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Okay. Nein, das Ding wird
schon mal für mich komplett, komplett
flachfallen.
Für mich sieht das nicht so aus, als wäre
ich gehört an Priorität. Also, ähm,
Projekteinsatz
am Wohnort.
Vergiss es.
Ich hab keinen Bock, drei Monate
in München oder so, wobei München geht noch.
München ist eigentlich ganz nice, ja.
Ähm, aber ich hab keinen Bock,
drei Monate irgendwo rumzugammeln, am Arsch der Welt,
weil da irgendein Projekt ist.
Kinderbetreuung ist für mich egal.
Kantine.
Gut, Kantine brauchst du in Frankfurt eigentlich nicht.
Ist aber nice, haben wir auch.
Es ist, genau,
24 Tage sind's, ja.
Ja, ja, 24.
Stand auch grad bei Wikipedia.
Essenszulage.
Im Office findet sich stets
und kostenlos Äpfel, Bananen,
Kiwi, Mandarinen, Traumka...
Wie, keine Schnitzel?
Hehehe.
Ähm, übrigens,
Kinderbetreuung ist nicht verkehrt, ja.
Weil's der Moon Eater Baku grade schreibt, also...
Das ist auf jeden Fall
ein großer Pluspunkt.
Der Rest nicht so sehr.
Das hier ist auch ganz nice, aber
jetzt nix, wo ich sagen würde, oh ja, muss unbedingt
sein. Gesundheitsmaßnahmen.
Okay, ja.
Auch okay.
Das ist auch ganz gut.
Äh, haben wir auch.
War ich einmal, und nie wieder.
Bin ich zu faul für.
Ähm...
Künstliche Anbindung,
Parkmöglichkeiten, ist für mich...
Mobilität, Bahncard, okay, das ist aber auch...
Zuschuss.
Fahrkostenzuschuss ist gut, oder Jobtickets,
das sind beide Sachen, die
sind gut und die sparen auch Geld und
die bringen richtig
richtig was an Kohle, ja.
Ähm...
Wenn man zum Beispiel ein Ticket bezahlt
oder Zuschläge zu einem Ticket kriegt,
sagen wir mal 100 Euro im Monat,
dann sind das
einfach schon mal 1200 Euro
im Jahr. Oder sagen wir mal, wenn ein Monat
11.100 Euro
im Jahr, das ist schon mal ein bisschen was.
Mitarbeiterhandys, ja.
Das ist kein Vorteil.
Das ist kein Vorteil, das sieht nur so aus.
Ähm...
Letztendlich ist das eine Consulting-
Beratungsfirma, die wollen, dass
du erreichbar bist. Das ist reiner Selbstzweck,
Mitarbeiterhandys.
Reiner Selbstzweck.
Internetnutzung, wir sind...
Ja, das ist auch normal,
dass man intern...
Also ich weiß, es gibt viele Firmen, die in Deutschland
immer noch rum, rum
ähm...
tricksen und machen und nicht wollen,
dass Mitarbeiter auch mal privat
was im Internet gucken, aber das finde ich ist
2019 und vor allem bei einem Unternehmen,
was mit IT was zu tun hat, nicht mal zeitgemäß,
ja. Ähm...
Es ist vollkommen normal,
vor allem, wenn du so auf flexibel
und dynamisch und sonst was machst, dass ich
selbstverständlich nebenbei
ein zweites
Fenster aufhaben kann, wo ich
beispielsweise meinen privaten Twitter-Feed oder so hab.
Also wenn man schon modern
dynamisch ist, dann sollte sowas Standard sein.
Weiterbildung, Coaching, blablabla.
Okay, ehrlich gesagt, eigentlich wurscht,
spricht mich nicht an.
Spricht mich nicht an.
Okay, wir machen mal
andere Musik an. Was haben wir hier?
Clear Sky, Best Chills.
Oh!
Wupp, wupp, wupp.
Hafti.
Hafti Abi gibt keinen Fick.
Okay, einen gucken wir noch.
Dann machen wir, dann machen wir
Nextcloud.
Pentasus.
Also, wir hatten echt Glück,
ne, die erste Stellenanzeige war ziemlich gut.
Hörst du noch Deutsche? Ich hab noch nie wirklich
großartig Deutschrap gehört. Ich hör das eigentlich
immer nur zur Belustigung. Ähm...
Die erste Anzeige war echt gut.
Ich mein,
wir bieten war ein bisschen schwach, aber
der Rest hat ein rundes Bild ergeben.
Also das ist was, wo man sich, wo ich mir tatsächlich
überlegen kann, okay, da könnte
man sich bewerben, ja. Die andere,
die wir bisher, die anderen zwei, die haben mir überhaupt
nicht gefallen. Ähm...
Okay, was haben die hier denn zu bieten?
Das Stellenangebot
von Vodafone hatten wir noch nicht, das ist das letzte.
Wollen wir das noch gucken?
Wollen wir noch Vodafone
gucken, bevor, bevor Nextcloud kommt?
Wir gucken jetzt erst mal die hier.
Pentasys, Docker. Ist das für sie etwas als
ein Hafenarbeiter?
Ich würde jetzt eigentlich davon ausgehen, dass jemand, der
das liest, weiß, was Docker ist.
Der Frau ist super.
Starnal München, Stuttgart, Frankfurt. Wir sind Pentasys.
Wir optimieren Geschäftsprozesse durch
smarte IT-Lösungen seit 20 Jahren.
Die Büros, bla.
Das Gute, unsere Projekte werden
immer vielzähliger.
Und vielfältiger.
Das Beste unseren Kollegen und Kollegen.
Okay, sind sie zumindest von überzeugt.
Ein bisschen schlecht.
Viele neue Kollegen für unsere Entwicklerteams
versuchen DevOps-Engineers für kunden-spezifische
bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla.
Bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla.
Okay, das müssen wir eigentlich gar nicht lesen.
Das ist sehr nichtssagend,
aber immerhin ein bisschen
Fülltext.
Ihre Aufgaben, okay.
Ähm.
Ist eigentlich gedacht, dass man das liest so?
Wir lesen es mal so.
Ähm.
Mit
Spaß an der Arbeit moderne Cloud-Native-Software.
Das ist auch so ein
Buzzword-Begriff, Cloud-Native.
Ähm. Das kann dir keiner so genau erklären,
was das ist, ne?
Das ist genauso wie
Microservices. Kann dir auch keiner
so genau erklären, wo ein Service anfängt
und wo ein Microservice beginnt und wo ein Microservice
aufhört und ein Service beginnt und
so wie das halt mit Buzzwords ist.
Für den Kunden entwickeln dabei die
Toolchain und Umgebung gestalten.
Ja, zum Glück ist es nicht die Blockchain.
Ähm.
Aber in der modernen Cloud-Plattform gestalten
bla bla bla bla bla bla
äh und gestalten
um Anwendungen schnell auszurollen und zu betreiben.
Das ist alles schon.
Das ist auf jeden Fall schon mal mit dem
mit der Stellenbeschreibung
deckt sich das, ja.
Anwendungen schnell auszurollen und zu betreiben
das ist was, was ich schon hier in diesem
DevOps-Bereich zählen würde.
Dabei sind sie Teil eines agilen Teams.
Okay.
Das eigenständig kundenspezifische Software entwickelt
und den Betrieb gewährleistet.
Okay, passt auch.
Die Qualität gewährleisten sie über moderne
Continuous Integration, Continuous Delivery Umgebung
in Kombination mit Test
und Automatisierung. Alles
passt dazu. Ja, ist nicht
so wie bei dieser einen Stelle,
wo man Druckerpatronen tauschen sollte.
Das hat auch wenigstens was mit DevOps zu tun.
Ähm.
Unsere Projektvielfalt.
Als Teil unserer bla bla bla
nutzen wir moderne. Ah, das sind ja die Microservices.
Moderne Cloud-Infrastruktur
und Microsoft-Service-Architekturen.
Ihre Kenntnisse in der objektorientierten
Programmierung setzen sie mittels aktueller
Java-Sprachfeatures auf.
IntelliJ ist zumindest nicht Eclipse.
Oh, Eclipse!
Ich hab nicht weiter gelesen.
Alter Teufel,
weiche, ey.
Ich bräuchte noch so ein Exorzisten
äh äh äh
Emote.
Okay.
Muss nicht schlecht sein, aber wahrscheinlich eher nichts für mich.
IntelliJ
ist gut, ja. IntelliJ ist die einzige
Java-IDE, die ich mag.
Und dann auch nicht für Java
zu entwickeln, sondern mit dem Rust-Plugin
ist die für Rust ganz gut.
Äh, der Milchmann hat übrigens recht.
Also es ist schon mal gut, dass hier verschiedene IDEs drinnen
stehen, ja. Das ist generell
ein gutes Zeichen, wenn irgendwo sowas steht wie
freie Betriebssystemwahl,
freie IDE-Wahl
oder sowas in der Richtung. Das ist immer
ein gutes Zeichen für, dass die
das mit agil auch so meinen, wie sie sagen.
Perspektiven für DevOps-Engineers
Okay, Weiterentwicklung ist das
aber wir bieten ihnen
flexible Arbeitszeiten, da haben wir's wieder.
Äh
Erfolgsbeteiligung
Das kann gut sein.
Reiseprämie
Heißt das, die wollen, dass man wieder irgendwo
rumhockt, ein paar Monate, paar Wochen.
Übernahme von
Reisekosten in Vorleistung. Dass da so
oft Reisekosten drin
vorkommt, ist immer so ein bisschen
so ein bisschen so ein rotes Tuch für mich.
Weil ich hab kein Problem da irgendwie
wenn man sagt, hey der hauptsächliche Standort
der Firma ist sagen wir jetzt mal irgendwie in
München und zweimal im Jahr
ist da irgendwie eine Veranstaltung, da müssen halt
alle hin. Das ist okay.
Aber wenn da gleich was von Leistung
und Reise und sowas drinnen steht
ähm
dann heißt das für mich eher, als ist das so ein Ding
wie, als hockst du mal in München, mal in
Stuttgart, mal in Frankfurt, mal in Hamburg, mal in Düsseldorf
mal in Nürnberg und mal bei
irgendeinem Kunde und sonst was.
Das ist eher nicht, nicht so das.
Vermögenswirksame Leistung, na gut
das müssen sie.
Ich glaub das ist
okay, ich
bin mir da rechtlich nicht
so sicher, ob sie das müssen, aber
es gibt zumindest keinen, den ich kenne, der das nicht
macht. Äh Buch
Budget.
Pimp your IT Budget.
Das heißt ich kann mir jetzt ein
ein Ruby Buch bestellen und krieg das bezahlt.
Was natürlich wahrscheinlich krasse
Investitionen für die Firma an.
Suchst du einen neuen Job oder guckst du einfach mal
ähm
ja, ja, nee, also
nee, nee, ja, je nachdem, also
ich suche nicht wirklich
einen neuen Job. Ich kann
seit 1.1.2019
aber einen neuen Job suchen, weil vorher
konnte ich nicht. Also vorher
war ich quasi vertraglich so
gebunden, dass ich nicht konnte, aber jetzt kann ich.
Und ähm, ich will aber nicht unbedingt.
Es sei denn, es gibt was geiles.
Da bin ich, bin ich dafür zu haben,
ja. Ähm und eigentlich haben wir
nur aus Spaß gesagt, wir können uns mal ein paar Stellen anzeigen.
angucken. Max, kann man
das als Emote nehmen?
Ja, das finde ich gut.
Das finde ich gut als
Das finde ich, das ist ein
gutes Emote, wenn
jemand was von Java schreibt.
Das Problem ist, man müsste
ihr könnt ja mal gucken, ob es den
auch transparent gibt.
Ohne die Küche im Keller.
Ähm
So, wir gucken jetzt die Anzeige noch fertig und danach
noch schnell Vodafone und dann machen wir Nextcloud.
Fuck, es ist schon, alter
es ist ja schon wieder, ich bin schon wieder
2 Stunden on, ey, warum geht die Zeit
übelst schnell rum?
Krass, oder?
Umfeld, hochqualität, blablabla
Community, Fest, Feste
gehören zum Programm.
Ich hasse Menschen und hasse Feste.
Da gehe ich immer nicht hin.
Wir haben auch Weihnachtsfeier, Sommerfest,
äh, bla, mit dem Außendienstfest.
Hast du nicht gesehen, Fest.
Bei uns gibt es alle, alle, äh,
naselang mal irgendwelche Veranstaltungen.
Ich gehe immer nicht hin.
Ich bin halt, äh, Kellerkind, ja.
Hehe.
Warum ist die Musik auf einmal so laut?
Okay, ähm,
da gucken wir uns mal Vodafone an.
Was Vodafone so haben möchte.
Achso, ne, haben wir
noch gar nicht fertig. Dazu noch interne
Coding Dojos. Ja, das ist
so eine, was kann man sich darunter vorstellen?
Das ist eine Veranstaltung, wo
du entweder
irgendwelche
Aufgaben
versuchst möglichst elegant zu lösen.
Mit, mit, mit
Leuten zusammen. Es kommt drauf an, was man da macht.
Ja, oder im Prinzip ist es
ein bisschen sowas wie eine Weiterbildung, ja.
Man sitzt halt
zusammen. Also was ich kenne
ist, dass man da sowas, das nennt sich dann Cutters,
das so ein bisschen so wie die krassen Karatefighter
Leute, äh, macht, dass man sich
zum Beispiel, dass man sich eine Aufgabe
sucht und versucht die dann quasi
gemeinsam besonders elegant,
ähm,
oder besonders kurz und knackig, besonders
elegant, besonders schön zu lesen,
äh, zu lösen.
Das macht Spaß mit den richtigen Leuten. Das macht wirklich Spaß.
Also zum Beispiel, zum Beispiel
hier mein, meine,
mein, mein, mein Chat, Chatprogramm
hier, ne. Das ist sowas, das könnte man
als Aufgabe nehmen. Da setzt man sich einfach mit fünf
Leuten hin und überlegt sich, hey, wie kann man das
möglichst kurz, prägnant, elegant
machen? Ähm, das wäre so ein Beispiel sowas,
was man in so einem Coding Dojo machen könnte.
Es kommt ein bisschen drauf an, was die jeweilige
Firma darunter versteht.
Ähm,
Anforderungen. Sie haben bereits Erfahrung mit Containern
wie Docker, yo, mit mindestens einer
Cloud-Plattform wie AWS, Azure,
ja, Vydus, ähm,
GCP, ich glaub das ist die Google-Geschichte,
ne, äh, Kubernetes,
oder, ich mein,
das passt, alles, das passt nicht so
ganz zusammen. Das da
kann ich ohne Probleme, äh, selbst
kosten und es ist alleine keine Cloud-
Plattform. Das da sind wirkliche
Cloud-Plattformen, die, wo ich keinen Einfluss drauf
hab. Auf Linux-Systeme sind sie zu Hause
und Virtualisieren ist auch für sie kein Fremdwort.
Tja, wenn ich, wenn ich irgendwo
zu Hause bin, dann sind's Linux-Systeme.
Äh,
am liebsten ist ihnen jedoch eine automatisierte
Umgebung in Infrastructure as
Code. Kommt immer drauf an, für was.
Sie sind zur Not auch mit
Chef oder Ansible bereitstellend.
Ja, kann ich auch machen. Sogar mit
beidem, wenn's sein muss.
Ist, äh, Ansible, Chef und Puppet,
Puppet war ja in der, in der Sache vorher drinne,
in der Schnellanzeige vorher, schlägt
alles in die gleiche Kerbe, dass man, äh,
Konfig-Dateien erstellt für nen,
für nen Tool, was dann wiederum anhand dieser
Konfig-Dateien Systeme automatisch
bereitstellt und gleich aufbaut.
Äh, zudem
bringen sie praktische Erfahrungen in der Entwicklung von
Java, nein, und Node.js,
ja, basierten Lösungen mit CI,
CD-Tools wie Jenkins, ja, klar.
Äh, gefällt mir nicht.
Okay, Vodafone.
Wo ist Vodafone?
Schon wieder die.
Ah. Ach, die
waren das hier.
Ah, ist auch Vodafone.
Was ist mit Infrastructure
as Code gemeint? Das ist wieder so'n
richtig, äh, eigentlich ein ziemlich
blöde Bezeichnung.
Mit Infrastructure as a Code gemeint
ist, dass man eben zum Beispiel
so'n Tool wie Ansible, Chef,
äh, oder Puppet oder
was gibt's da noch, SaltStack
und es gibt noch ein paar andere Dinge hat,
also quasi Tools, die anhand von
Source Code Systeme
provisionieren, konfigurieren,
automatisch aufbauen,
und wenn man halt diesen
Source Code für diese Tools nimmt
und vielleicht noch in ein Git oder
eine Versionsverwaltung reinhaut,
das ist im Prinzip
Infrastructure as Code.
Ist total beknackter Begriff.
Ähm, entdecke
den Pioniergeist in dir.
Okay, mal schauen, was Vodafone
so will. Du bist bereit für
eine Zukunft, die so aufregend sein wird
wie nie. Ja, bei Vodafone bin ich mir
da sicher. Ähm, bist du
bereit für eine Welt voller neuer
digitaler Möglichkeiten? Bereit
für Vodafone. Ich kann mir so richtig
vorstellen, wie das der, wie das
der Vodafone Recruit-Typ erzählt,
so nach dem Motto, bist du bereit für eine
Zukunft, die so aufregend sein wird wie nie?
Und die Leute, die dann davor sind, sagen, jaaa!
Ah, bist du bereit
für eine Welt voller neuer digitaler Möglichkeiten?
Jaaa!
Bereit für Vodafone!
Kann ich mir richtig vorstellen.
Ähm,
dann verbinde dein Können
mit besten Aussichten als
Se... Oh!
Ja, das ist ja eigentlich das Richtige
für mich. Ich mach das ja schon ein paar...
Ich wollt grad sagen, ein paar
Jahrzehnte, das ist aber
dann doch ein bisschen übertrieben. So alt
bin ich doch nicht. Aber ein Jahrzehnt
mach ich's schon.
Also das da.
Ich mach ja DevOps schon zu Zeiten, wo es nicht mal
DevOps hieß. Das war der Witz dabei.
Hast du das
MWW gelesen? Oh! Oh je!
Oh je!
Da ist die Anzeige raus.
Für was soll das MWW
stehen? Männlich, weiß,
wenig Haaren. Keine Ahnung.
Nein,
das soll ein D sein und soll wahrscheinlich für
männlich, weiblich, divers stehen. Sie haben sich
irgendwie ein bisschen vertan.
Was auch immer. Männlich, weiblich,
was auch immer. Kann auch sein.
Männlich, weiß, wichtig.
Okay, also was
will der MOW davon? Du willst die digitale Welt
verändern. Dann bist du in
unserem Team Gold richtig. Wir sind
digitale Weiterdenker
und suchen kreative Köpfe und innovative
Ideen. IT Visionäre
und Macher, die der digitalen
Telekommunikation den Weg bereiten.
Schnell und innovativ.
Experten, die wissen, dass
Geschwindigkeit Zukunft bedeutet
und die unseren Kunden immer
die schnellste aller Lösungen liefern.
Nimm die Herausforderung an,
die deutschlandweit 40 Millionen
Vodafone Kunden in die digitale
Zukunft zu führen.
Okay.
Das sind deine Herausforderungen.
Du automatisierst generische
applikationsspezifische
Deployment
Pipelines im
was?
Im Center of Excellence
Okay, das habe ich noch nie
gehört, ehrlich gesagt.
Du automatisierst
generische und applikationsspezifische
Deployment Pipelines im
Center of Excellence
Kann das sein, dass das
gar nicht reingehört in diesen Satz?
Ohne
würde der Satz einen Sinn ergeben.
Ich habe das noch nie gehört.
Ich habe das wirklich
Yeti, nee nicht Yeti.
Ich habe das noch nie gehört.
Weiß nicht, was das ist.
Shared Facility
Ich habe immer noch keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Was ist das?
Ja, was ist, äh, dann
Äh, Yeti,
erklär mal, was das ist. Ich habe wirklich
keine Ahnung. Es ist nicht mal gefaked.
Ich habe keinen Schirm, was Center of Excellence ist.
Continuous Integration und Deployment
Äh
CD müsste
Continuous Delivery sein, eigentlich.
Es ist nicht Continuous Deployment. Das heißt nicht,
dass es Delivery ist, eigentlich.
Unser IT-Organisation. Okay, das passt für
Das passt für DevOps-Engineer auf jeden Fall.
Schon mal ziemlich gut.
Du definierst und konzipierst
Standards für Pipelines,
Tools, Prozesse und Umgebungen.
Public Cloud
passt auch wunderbar zu DevOps-Engineer.
Also es ist nicht so wie
die zweite Anzeige, die wir gelesen haben,
die einen Admin wollten und einen Projektmanager.
Oh, Knärbeeren-Eis.
Moment.
Ich will da kurz ein Bild adden.
Zu meinem
zu meinem
Meme-Tool.
Und zwar diese
Domain. Zack.
Wow.
Ich hoffe, das ist auch transparent.
Bild speichern unter.
Äh.
Teufel.
Desktop.
Hinzufügen.
Was ist denn hier da?
Ups.
Ah, funktioniert. Okay.
Also wenn jetzt mal wieder was mit Java
angesagt ist, habe ich das passende Bild dazu.
Ähm.
Du übernimmst die Vendor- und Domain-
übergreifende Abstimmung von strategischen
Deployment-Konzepten und Architekturen.
Das ist auch
sehr vage
formuliert.
Das würde ich aber auch sagen,
passt zu der Stelle.
Du berätst Fachbereiche bei der Einführung
und Nutzung von. Das ist auch passend
für als DevOps-Engineer.
Ähm.
Du koordinierst die reibungslose
und störungsfreie
Enterprise. Moment.
Ist das Enterprise-to-Enterprise?
Can be to be?
End-to-End. Ah. End-to-End.
Logisch. Eigentlich logisch, dass es
End-to-End ist.
Klingt auch viel logischer als
Enterprise-to-Enterprise.
End-to-End.
Innerhalb von Großprojekten.
Du koordinierst die reibungslose
und störungsfreie End-to-End
Implementierung von Applikationen
innerhalb von Großprojekten.
Du koordinierst die reibungslose
und störungsfreie
End-to-End
Implementierung.
Meinen die damit, dass wenn
in einem Projekt
mehrere Applikationen entwickelt werden,
dass man dann dafür sorgen
soll, dass die
miteinander gescheit können?
Ist das damit gemeint?
Ansonsten fällt es mir gerade schwer,
mir da einen Reim drauf zu machen,
was mir der Satz sagen soll.
Du bringst mit ein abgeschlossenes
...
Da bin ich ja schon mal raus.
Vertiefte Kenntnisse in
heterogenen Betriebssystemen und Datenbanken.
Oracle.
Unix.
Also von Datenbanken habe ich
eigentlich eine rudimentäre Ahnung.
Also ich kann ein paar
Joints programmieren, ja. Ich kann,
prinzipiell, ich bin aber kein
DBA.
Mit Linux kenne ich mich ziemlich gut aus.
Gängige Cloud-Architektur,
je nachdem, was wir haben wollen, auch.
Mindestens 8 Jahre Berufserfahrung in der IT
sowie, ich habe sogar über 10 Jahre
Erfahrung im DevOps-Bereich. Also wenn ich da nicht
Senior DevOps bin, da weiß ich
auch nicht.
Tiefes Verständnis von hochkritischem
und großvolumigem IT-System.
Das kann man so sagen.
Ist bei uns nicht viel anders.
Sehr gute Englischkenntnisse in Wort und Schrift.
Ich glaube, da wollen sie,
was auch immer das irgendwie für ein Standard ist,
da wollen sie wahrscheinlich was, was
ich nicht hinkriege.
Also so richtig, richtig krassen
Business-Smalltalk auf Englisch
kriege ich nicht gebacken.
Ich kann mich mit Leuten auf Englisch
verständigen. Und die wissen auch,
was ich will. Und vor allem, wenn es um technische Sachen geht,
ist das eh einfacher.
Aber das da, was auch immer B2 ist,
das habe ich wahrscheinlich nicht.
Ach, B2 ist Abi-Niveau.
Kann man das nicht hinschreiben?
Ah, diese Stelle kann in Vollzeit
oder vollzeitnaher Teilzeit ausgübt werden.
Das ist schon mal gut für mich.
Weil ich will ja nicht Vollzeit.
Ich will ja eigentlich nur
30 Stunden. Ja. Ach, Moment, aber
das gab es ja gar nicht in Frankfurt.
Ja, dann fällt es für mich eh schon mal, eh schon mal raus.
Was bieten sie denn?
Attraktive Vergütung und überdurchschnittliche
Zusatzleistungen. Betriebliche Altersvorgaben
umfassende Weiterbildung, individuelle
Verhältnisse und Talente, flexible Arbeitszeitmodelle
und Homeoffice. Das kann was
Gutes sein. Das kann auch
was Schlechtes sein.
Aktive Unterstützung bei der Kinderbetreuung.
Das ist gut. Pflege von Angehörigen.
Das ist auch gut.
Vielfältige Gesundheitsangebote. Das ist auch gut.
Internationale
Karrierechancen und Austauschmöglichkeiten.
Ja, okay.
Ja, ich muss sagen, so schlecht ist die
Vodafone-Anzeige gar nicht.
Ich glaube nicht, dass sie genau mich suchen
würden.
Oder ich glaube nicht, dass ich, sag mal umgedreht, ich glaube nicht, dass ich
da richtig gut drauf
passen würde, aber
oder je nachdem, wo sie den Schwerpunkt
drauf legen, würde ich da schon ziemlich gut
drauf passen, aber es ist eh nicht
in Frankfurt. Ne, es ist
in, ach doch, in Eschborn.
Ach, hab ich ja gar nicht gelesen. Ich dachte
die ganze Zeit in Düsseldorf sind die.
Ja, in Eschborn ist kein Ding. Nach Eschborn
ist Eads. Da bin ich, bin ich
20 Minuten da oder so.
Ohne
Studium, Studium, kein Job da.
Das ist die Frage.
Ich meine, die schreiben das zwar hier,
ähm, ob das
wirklich Anforderung ist,
wenn man schon quasi 15,
15 Jahre Erfahrung in dem Gebiet hat,
ist wahrscheinlich
davon abhängig,
ähm, wie sie das sehen, ja.
Also, wenn die jemand wissen wollen,
der weiß, wovon er, also jemand haben wollen,
der weiß, wovon er spricht, der DevOps schon
gemacht hat zu Zeiten, wo das Ganze noch nicht mal
DevOps hieß,
dann werden die ja wahrscheinlich, äh,
nicht so viele finden, die
das schon so lange machen.
Ja, äh, seh ich nämlich
auch so, Danny. Deswegen, ich glaub, da schreiben
die einfach nur mal so als Hürde rein, falls jemand sagt,
oh ja, ich hab jetzt fertig studiert und kenn
mich voll gut aus. Ähm, aber
ich mein, hey, sie schreiben Senior,
das heißt auf jeden Fall, du bist
nicht frisch fertig mit irgendwas,
ähm, und sie schreiben auch hier 8 Jahre.
Und 8 Jahre
ist, ist schon sehr Senior.
Normalerweise würd ich sagen, ey, du kannst,
du kannst normalerweise nach,
nach 3 Jahren kannst du da schon als Senior
durchgehen, je nachdem, wie und wo und
was. Ähm,
aber 8 Jahre ist schon ne ordentliche
Geschichte. Ist schon ne
lange, ähm,
lange Anforderung, mindestens 8 Jahre.
Ja, bei mir ist noch länger.
Aber,
tja.
Tja. Ach, an sich find ich die Anzeige
gar nicht so schlecht. Ich glaub, ich hätt, ich hätt
keinen großartigen Bock auf Vodafone jetzt,
um ehrlich zu sein. Aber, ich mein, wenn das, wenn das
drum rum passen würde. Also, ich muss sagen, ich hab
mir jetzt Schlimmeres vorgestellt, nachdem man sie ja
Vodafone als Anbieter so kennt. Ähm,
ich glaub, ich weiß sogar,
wo das ist. Falls das
das in Frankfurt ist, dann weiß ich glaub ich, wo das
ist. Ähm,
glaub ich weiß, wo das ist.
Äh, nicht Shopping.
Ach, ne, doch nicht.
Dann ist das Düsseldorf.
Ne, das weiß ich nicht, wo das ist.
Aber lass mal gucken. Ähm,
das ist,
da komm ich locker hin.
Das ist,
da bin ich
in einer halben Stunde morgens da.
Ah,
sag mal, 35,
40 Minuten bin ich morgens da.
Mein aktuell
ist mein Arbeitsweg halt von hier drüben
quasi zum Südbahnhof.
Der Südbahnhof ist da unten.
Äh,
da,
da fahr ich aktuell morgens immer
hin, so von hier drüben hierher.
Dann lauf ich hier hoch. Ich zeig's jetzt nicht so genau.
Ähm,
dann würd ich einfach zum Hauptbahnhof fahren.
Also, nicht, dass ich mich jetzt bei denen
bewerben würde. Ich sag ja, ich überleg nur grad mal, ne.
Ähm,
dann würd ich einfach hier hochfahren zum Hauptbahnhof
und fahr ich mit der S-Bahn
dahin. Das dürfte, das dürfte
ziemlich easy as a fuckes sein.
Ja. Okay.
Äh, machen wir in einem der nächsten
Streams noch mal, machen wir noch mal weiter.
Ich würd sagen, wir können uns ab und zu mal so
zwei, drei Stellenanzeigen schon mal
gönnen.
Facelik, genau. Über Google,
über, über Google, Google Earth, Facelik.
Das Satellit hat quasi durchs
Fenster gesumt. Ich muss mal
kurz Licht anmachen. Zu dunkel.
Genau, Licht, dass ich mich
besser in Google Maps spiegel.
Oh. Okay.
Ähm, Knärbär. Was mir
an Nextcloud nicht so gut gefallen hat,
es sind, eigentlich sind es Kleinigkeiten.
Allerdings, ich finde recht,
ähm,
bedeutende,
recht bedeutende Kleinigkeiten. Erstens
hatte ich mal Probleme mit dem Sync.
Da haben Dateien konfliktet
und ich hab nicht gecheckt, warum.
Ich hab die auch nicht parallel editiert
oder so. Oder es waren mindestens mal fünf
Minuten dazwischen. Und
der Konflikt ließ sich auch nicht so ordentlich, ordentlich
lösen irgendwie. Es war sehr merkwürdig.
Was daraus geführt hat, dass der eine,
die eine Seite irgendwie überhaupt keine Dateien mal richtig
geschrieben hat. Ganz merkwürdig. Also ich mein,
Dateien
Sync ist, ist eines der Haupt
Aufgaben
von, von Nextcloud.
Äh, wir müssen uns mal die Changelogs
angucken, was da so passiert ist.
Ich würde sagen, wir machen die richtige
Nextcloud-Installation, machen wir dann morgen. Oder mal gucken,
wie lange, vielleicht machen wir das heute auch noch.
Äh, ich hab ja eigentlich Zeit.
Äh, wie heißt,
wie heißt nochmal das Backuptool, was du benutzt?
Borg-Backup. Ähm, dann hatte ich noch
das Problem mit Nextcloud, das ist auch eine
Sache, die ich mir angucken wollte.
Ähm, dass das, äh, Tool,
die, die Notizen-App,
kompletter Crap gewesen ist. Da hat nur immer die Suche
funktioniert. Und wozu brauchst du
eine Notiz-App, wo die Suche nicht
funktioniert? Ist mobil kein Problem,
da hast du, da hast du lokale
Apps. Und auf dem Desktop kannst du theoretisch
auch lokale Apps haben, aber wenn's ne Web-App
für Notizen gibt und die keine Suche
hat, ist schon
bescheuert. Die
Do-App war auch Müll, die hatte auch keine richtige
Suche. Ähm,
und wahrscheinlich auch ein paar Kleinigkeiten.
Ich glaub, ich hab aktuell noch Nextcloud 14 drauf.
Ne, hab ich nicht.
Ich hab Nextcloud. Wann kam
14 raus?
Ich muss mal kurz gucken, was ich für ne, für ne Nextcloud-Version
bei mir aktuell habe.
Weiß die IP gar nicht.
Na geil. Ähm,
muss ich mal kurz nachgucken.
Settings. Hab ich da
richtig gemacht? Ah, hier.
Slash Nextcloud.
Und ich hab irgendwie englische Tastaturbelegung wieder.
Mal kurz gucken, was ich
für ne Version hab.
Okay, ähm, ich hab die
Nextcloud-Version, das sieht man auch bestimmt
im Admin-Interface
irgendwo. 13
hab ich. Nextcloud 13 hab ich
noch. Also da hat sich
sehr viel getan dazwischen.
Was ist der Vorteil von Nextcloud
gegenüber, sagen wir mal, einem Samba-Server?
Äh, dass du die Dateien syncen kannst. Samba-Server
ist ja, also eigentlich ist
Dateien-Sync ja das komplette
Gegenteil von einem Samba-Server.
Samba-Server ist zentral,
wo man drauf zugreift
und ein Sync von Dateien heißt,
sie liegen letztendlich
auch auf unterschiedlichen
Systemen dann.
Ähm, ja genau. Und du hast
ne History, was sich geändert hat und wer was geändert hat
und so. Das ist nicht so wichtig. Aber
im Falle des Samba-Servers, wenn der Samba-Server
im Arsch ist, sind die Dateien im Arsch.
Hast du deine Dateien gesynct auf
drei Rechner, dann sind die halt auf drei Rechner noch da.
Und ähm,
man benutzt das eigentlich hauptsächlich
für Sachen, die
relativ klein sind.
Also für irgendwelche Notizen oder sonst was.
Oder aber, was auch beliebt ist, um
Fotos, die man gemacht hat, direkt
direkt in ein Fotoalbum zu
syncen oder sowas. Ist
ein bisschen anders gelagert als ein zentraler
File-Server und natürlich
ich kann auf meinem Smartphone
ähm
beispielsweise Notizen machen, Fotos
machen, Kontakte hinzufügen, To-Dos schreiben
und äh
und das dann zu meinem Server
syncen und alle anderen Geräte sehens.
Entweder habe ich den Zugang von außen
zu meinem Server, dass ich direkt syncen kann
oder aber, mein Smartphone syncht
einfach dann, wenn ich
daheim bin und ins WLAN gehe, automatisch.
Es ist halt auch
irgendwie ne Komfort-Sache.
Okay, was hab ich gesagt?
Ich hab gesagt, ich hab Nextcloud
13.
Das heißt, da gucken wir doch mal
was da alles so
gekommen ist mit Nextcloud 14.
Nextcloud
14. Wir, wir, wir
gucken uns das in Zusammenfassung an.
Wir gucken uns das in Zusammenfassung an.
Ach, guck mal,
die hat bei Wikipedia ne schöne Übersicht, das ist ja nice.
Also, bei 14 ist dazu gekommen
ähm, im Detail natürlich
noch viel weitere, viel mehr Verbesserungen.
Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung kam dazu.
Video-Verifizierung
des Empfängers. Nextcloud
Talk. The fuck?
Okay.
Wusste ich gar nicht, dass die irgendwie so ne, so ne
so ein neues auf Discord
machen oder so.
Weitere Neuerungen. Prüfung
aller installierten Apps auf Kompatibilität.
Okay. Die Bedienung wurde
überarbeitet. Oh, das ist auch ganz gut.
Ein dunkles Design. Oh, das ist nice.
Das ist, da freu ich
mich. Das, das Nextcloud
Design hat mir ehrlich gesagt nie so gut gefallen.
Das war, das Blau auf Weiß.
Warum updatest du nicht? Weil ich schlechte Erfahrungen
mit Nextcloud Updates gemacht hab.
Und, weil's auf der falschen
Kiste läuft. In dem Fall ist es einfacher
neu zu installieren
und die Daten rüber zu ziehen,
anstatt ähm
quasi die
13er Installation zu upgraden und umzuziehen
oder umzuziehen und zu upgraden.
Viele Verbesserungen für barrierefreies
Arbeiten am Computer. Das, das ist immer gut.
Ich brauch's zwar nicht,
aber ich find's immer gut, wenn Software oder wenn,
wenn, wenn Hersteller drauf achten,
dass ihre Produkte
auch von Leuten benutzt werden können,
die vielleicht schlechter sehen oder
andere, anderweitig beeinträchtigt sind.
Ähm, Notizen
zu Freigaben, Teilen von Dateien
via Nextcloud Talk.
Notizen zu Freigaben?
Achso, zu Shares, okay.
Ähm, zwei Faktor-Authentifizierung durch
Klingt ganz, klingt ganz gut.
Ähm, Sicherheits-
Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung.
Das ist cool.
...
Das ist nice.
Das ist wirklich nice. Man müsste sich mal, man müsste sich
mal angucken, wie das implementiert ist.
Aber das ist richtig gut, weil, ähm,
ich kann natürlich
auf dem Server mein Laufwerk,
wo meine Nextcloud-Sachen
drauflegen.
Achso, ich beginne zur Version 13.
Ha, das hat meine Version schon.
Aber trotzdem ist das gut.
Ähm, trotzdem
ist, ja, ich seh's auch, ich hab mich
in die falsche Richtung, ja, Leute, ich hab's gesehen, ne.
Aber trotzdem ist das gut, ähm,
weil ich kann zwar die, die Platte
verschlüsseln, wo mein Nextcloud drauf liegt,
aber, wenn ich Dateien
synke, zum Beispiel auf mein, äh,
auf, auf mein iPhone oder auf
irgendein Android-Tablet oder sowas,
und die liegen da unverschlüsselt drauf rum,
sind die Dateien ja auch, bringt's mir ja
nix, wenn die auf dem Server-Verschlüssel liegen, ne.
Ja, das, das, das muss ich mir auf jeden Fall
mal genauer angucken.
Okay, Nextcloud 15.
Neue Social-App.
Unter anderem Mastadon.
Mastadon, das ist ein Mammut, oder? Ist Mastadon nicht ein Mammut?
Äh, mit dem Kommunikationsprotokoll
ActivityPub.
Social-App.
Naja.
So viele Leute verwenden meinen
Nextcloud nicht. Meine Mutter verwendet
Nextcloud, und ich verwende
meine Nextcloud.
Zwei Leute verwenden meine Nextcloud.
Unter MasterCover macht teilweise
Offsite-Backups drauf.
Das war's.
Ähm.
Ja, unter Clocks.HD verwenden wir meinen Nextcloud.
Gut.
Ist gut, dass du mir das mal sagst, wenigstens, ne.
Hast du, hast du besondere
Wünsche zu den Zeiten, wann ich die, wann ich
das upgraden darf? Wann brauchst du's
nicht? Ähm, okay.
Die Ladezeiten der Internetseite wurden verbessert.
Das ist immer gut. Mach einfach, ja.
Ähm.
Tiefere Integration von
Kollaborer online mit Chat-Funktionen.
Das ist cool. Äh,
Kallo... Kallo... Ach du Scheiße.
Ich kann's nicht aussprechen. Ist auch egal, wie's heißt.
Das ist OpenOffice
mit, ähm, oder LibreOffice
mit, ähm,
ein bisschen
Google-Documents-Flair.
Also, es ist LibreOffice,
LibreOffice, wo Leute quasi
zusammen editieren können.
Eigentlich ne coole Geschichte,
wenn man das braucht. Okay, und?
Ach, unterstützt bis.
Ah.
Okay. Ja, eh.
Ich bin doof manchmal, äh.
Ich dachte, was wollen sie mit im April 2020?
Wollte ich sagen. Es wird unterstützt
bis April 2020. Okay.
Und in Nextcloud kam, kam erst,
kam erst vor drei Monaten raus.
Also, was gibt's da für Neuerungen?
Neue Access-Control-Lists.
Können ältere
proprietäre File-Server ersetzen?
Okay.
Muss ich mal angucken.
Authentifizierung. Erkennung von
verdächtigen Anwälten aus...
Wow, jetzt wird's aber advanced.
Jetzt sperrt man nicht einfach
nach fünf, nach fünf
ähm,
unzulässigen Login-Versuchen einfach
die IP. Jetzt erkennt
man verdächtige Anmeldeaktivitäten
auch mit einem neuronalen Netzwerk.
Boah, big brain, äh.
Funktion Projekte.
Die Benutzer können ihre
Arbeit organisieren, indem sie verschiedene Ressourcen
zu Projekten zusammen... Ach, das ist cool.
Das ist cool. Das ist wirklich nice.
Man konnte, glaube ich, bisher schon Ordner
machen, aber das war nicht so schön.
Das ist wirklich ganz cool.
Da kann man ein Projekt anlegen,
zum Beispiel hier irgendwie, was weiß ich,
wenn ich was für die Arbeit mache von daheim,
könnte ich mir das beispielsweise, könnte ich mir einen Kalender
anlegen, wo ich mir eintrage, okay,
so lange hast du gearbeitet, oder
ein paar Ressourcen... Also,
es ist, das schließt sich ganz cool.
Äh, Nextcloud Talk
6.0. Gut, werde ich wahrscheinlich
nicht verwenden.
Interessant ist das auf jeden Fall, was
die da so getrieben haben.
Sag mal, ist das immer die gleiche Musik seit drei Stunden?
Nee.
Ist es nicht.
Max, was sagst du eigentlich
zu Office 365 für Schulen?
Das kam
ja in der letzten Woche mal wieder hoch.
Ich weiß nicht, ob man
an der Schule Office 365 braucht.
Wozu braucht man an der Schule Office
365? Was macht man da
so tolles in Office, dass man
Office 365 braucht?
Oder dass man überhaupt nen Office braucht?
Ich bin der Meinung, in der Regel, das, was du
in der Schule machst, wird wahrscheinlich
nen Texteditor reichen.
Ein bisschen Markdown drauf, und gut.
So, switchen wir mal auf
Linux rüber. Habe ich meinen Raspberry
von gestern noch an?
Nee, habe ich nicht an. Der hängt hier rum.
Der hängt hier rum
und ist nicht mehr am Strom angeschlossen.
Deswegen kann der auch nicht mehr an sein.
Muss ich mal anmachen.
So, jetzt ist er wieder an.
Ähm,
ich mein,
wenn man an der Schule nen Office
unbedingt braucht, warum nicht
Office 365?
Ich mein, ich
persönlich, wisst ihr ja, ich verwende überhaupt
keine Office-Programme.
Und ich bin der Ansicht, das einzige Office-Programm,
was eine Daseinsberechtigung
hat, ist Excel. Oder halt
Tabellenkalkulation.
Ich weiß nicht, auch letztens im Stream, quasi
die häufigste
Programmiersprache, die
die Programmiersprache, die die meisten Leute
können, ist Excel.
Oh Gott, MSProject.
Da wird's mal Zeit hierfür.
MSProject.
Es gibt ja kaum was Schlimmeres.
Ich hab mit MSProject
ein Gantt-Diagramm für meine Abschlussprüfung gemacht.
Das war ganz, das war ganz schlimm.
Allerdings ist für mich so
die Standard Office
Programme sind für mich Tabellenkalkulation,
Präsentationsprogramm,
Textverarbeitung,
ja,
so das Zeug. OneNote ist ganz gut,
ja.
Wobei ich an OneNote halt blöd finde.
Also OneNote ist so ein Ding,
alles oder nichts. Du musst, wenn du
OneNote verwendest, musst du theoretisch OneNote dann auch
überall verwenden, weil es ist halt kein
plain Text mehr.
Also ich bin schon dafür, dass man
an der Schule mal gezeigt
kriegt, wie eine Textverarbeitung funktioniert
oder wie eine
Tabellenkalkulation funktioniert, aber ganz ehrlich,
es
sollte sich nicht
so sehr auf Microsoft
Eigenheiten erstrecken. Man sollte den Leuten
beibringen, wie man einen Brief schreibt
und
das halt mal in der Tabellenkalkulation
machen. Das kann auch meinetwegen Word
sein. Allerdings,
man sollte die Schüler heute nicht
unterschätzen. Die sind doch nicht blöd.
Wenn du denen zeigst, wie
man einen Brief schreiben soll, denken die sich erst mal
lol alter, warum soll ich einen Brief schreiben, sowas
ist ja hier 2019.
Aber vielleicht müssen sie ja mal irgendeinem Amt
einen Brief schreiben oder sonst was.
Nein, die sind nicht blöd. In der Richtung sind die
nicht blöd.
Ich halte,
Leute, ich halte in der Regel,
defaultmäßig eigentlich jeden für blöd.
Aber ich halte nicht die Leute
bei uns in der Schule für zu blöd,
wenn die wissen,
wie man
eine Textverarbeitung bedient,
traue ich denen zu,
dass sie das ohne Probleme
in allen anderen
Textverarbeitungen auch hinbekommen.
Wenn die schon mal einen Brief geschrieben
haben in Word, schaffen
die das auch ohne Probleme, einen Brief
in LibreOffice zu schreiben oder einen Brief
in WordPad zu schreiben oder einen Brief in
diesem komischen ChinaOffice
zu schreiben. Ich habe jetzt vergessen, wie heißt
das ChinaOffice nochmal, irgendwie
KingSoftOffice oder so.
Ist das überhaupt das ChinaOffice?
Ja, das ist
das ChinaOffice ist das.
Oder was auch immer, also
wenn
Leute, die heute in der Schule
sind, wenn die eins können,
dann ist es
gelernte Sachen auf technischer Ebene
zu transferieren
zwischen Programmen.
Das können die, das machen die
jeden Tag. Das juckt heute
keinen mehr, ob du App A, B oder C
hast für irgendwas.
Wenn
man eines der Art kann, dann kann man
die andere auch.
Ich weiß nicht, ich glaube da
unterschätzt ihr die Leute.
Der Blockwatcher sagt, ich glaube
echt, heute haben Schüler weniger
Ahnung von PCs als vor 10 Jahren, Smartphones
sei Dank. Gut,
Desktop-PCs ist ja auch nicht mehr der heiße
Shit und selbst damals kannte sich nur
eine ganz beschränkte Gruppe wirklich gut mit
PCs aus.
Okay, ey, wenn ihr das sagt,
dann sagt aber nicht, ich habe
die Schüler von heute schlecht gemacht oder so.
Ich bin dann auch der, der das hier am optimistischsten
sieht. Allerdings sollte es die Aufgabe
in der Schule sein, dass man die
Leuten eben beibringt, nicht etwa
so funktioniert Microsoft Word,
sondern so schreibt man
einen Brief und so macht man das in der Textverarbeitung.
Und wenn man das in einer Textverarbeitung
kann und nicht komplett
beschränkt ist, kann man
das in jeder anderen Textverarbeitung aus.
Auch.
Nee, nicht in Slack-Gruppen, Microsoft Teams
ist doch jetzt angesagt.
Und eines der Hauptargumente,
die ja immer gebracht wird,
wenn Microsoft
Sachen den Kindern
oder den Leuten in der Schule beigebracht wird, ist,
ja, die Industrie
würde das verlangen.
Es ist nicht unbedingt,
zumindest ist das meine Sicht der Dinge,
es ist nicht unbedingt die Aufgabe,
den Schülern
an der Schule
nur das beizubringen,
was die Industrie haben will
oder was die Industrie sich wünscht.
Es ist wichtig, dass man den Leuten
das prinzipiell
erklärt,
ja, und
dass sie wissen, wie ein Brief aussieht,
zum Beispiel, ja, und
die Sache, wie das
jeweilige Unternehmen dann
diesen Brief in Software umgesetzt
haben will, das sollen sie gefälligst den Leuten sagen.
Selbst erklären.
Es geht darum, dass du weißt, wie es geht.
Nicht, dass du weißt, was du in Word klicken musst.
Mal ganz davon abgesehen, es ist ja auch total bescheuert.
Stellt euch mal vor, irgendjemand ist jetzt
in der, keine Ahnung, in der 6. Klasse
und die lernen jetzt,
ähm, wie man in Word
einen Brief schreibt.
Ihr glaubt doch nicht ernsthaft,
dass wenn der Typ mal arbeiten geht,
oder wenn die mal arbeiten geht,
dass dann Word noch so aussieht, wie damals in der Schule.
Word sieht alle 3 Jahre anders aus.
Zumindest anders genug,
als wenn das Thema funktioniert.
Bring ihnen Latex bei. Ja, genau.
Wenn du sie gleich verschrecken willst.
Wir haben auch genug Azubis, die vor nichts einen Plan haben.
Aber ob das besser wird,
wenn man ihnen jetzt quasi zeigt,
wo man in Word klicken muss, wage ich zu bezweifeln.
Ja, Saito sehe ich genauso.
Ein Texteditor
mit Markdown
ist eigentlich das Beste, was du machen kannst.
Da konzentrierst du dich aufs Wesentliche.
Nämlich, wie man
einen ordentlichen Text schreibt,
wie man das verständlich macht,
was dann formatiert,
ist Nebensache.
Und das ist halt in Markdown auch super easy.
Du machst eine Raute davor,
da hast du eine Überschrift,
machst zwei Rauten davor, hast eine kleinere Überschrift,
machst ein Minus davor, hast eine Liste.
Ein stinknormaler Texteditor
mit Markdown wäre wahrscheinlich echt das Beste.
Weil das lenkt dann auch nicht vom Wesentlichen ab,
sondern einfach, wie man den Mist tippt.
Ich kann es verstehen,
dass Schulen, also jetzt zum Thema,
was Gamer329 sagt,
ich verstehe zum Teil,
schon, dass
Schulen
ja, dass Schulen
Office und Windows verwenden.
Das liegt nämlich daran,
weil wir
nicht auf der Höhe der Zeit sind,
was Ausstattung und
Kenntnisse der Leute anbelangt.
Dass es oft genug noch so ist,
dass sich in der Schule Lehrer
ehrenamtlich um die Technik kümmern
und die meisten Lehrer schlicht und ergreifend
sich, wenn überhaupt, mit Office und Windows
auskennen.
Das ist einfach.
Und da wird sich wahrscheinlich auch nichts dran ändern.
Linux auf dem Desktop
können wir vergessen.
Also, das ist die letzten
15 Jahre nichts passiert
und wird die nächsten 10 Jahre
auch nichts mehr passieren.
Es sei denn, und das ist das einzige,
was ich mir vorstellen könnte,
dass es aus der Gaming-Richtung kommt.
Das ist das einzige, was ich mir vorstellen könnte.
Also, wenn das Valve
und irgendwie,
wenn da sich die Sterne
im passenden Winkel
ausrichten,
dass
der Erfolg von Linux
auf so einem 0-15-Rechner
tatsächlich über die Gaming-Seite
kommen wird, wenn überhaupt.
Weil, wenn einer auf den Microsoft misst
keinen Bock hat, dann ist das Valve.
Den geht das auch auf den Sack.
Volvo, ja.
Das ist das einzige, was ich mir vorstellen kann,
aber ich glaube nicht dran.
Also, wo ich komplett
den Glauben in die Linux-Entwickler
quasi...
Ne, nicht in die Linux-Entwickler, das stimmt nicht.
Die Kernel-Entwickler können dafür nämlich nichts.
Also, wo ich da ein bisschen den Glauben
drin verloren habe, ist,
dass man es auf die Reihe kriegt,
dass die Teams, die sich da hauptsächlich
um die großen Open-Source-Projekte kümmern,
dass es die auf die Reihe kriegen, wirklich
Anwendungen zu stricken,
bis auf ein paar Ausnahmen,
die die Leute dazu bringen, um zu steigen und zu benutzen.
Die Desktop-Landschaft unter Linux ist
lockste keinem
hinterm Mond mit hervor.
Vergleiche das mal
mit einem Mac. Es gibt ein paar Ausnahmen,
es gibt so Elementary-OS, das sieht ganz hübsch aus,
aber auch nur mit den Standard-Anwendungen.
Das Gute und Schlechte
zugleich unter Linux ist halt einfach,
dass es Wildwuchs ist.
Das ist nicht gut
und nicht schlecht, das ist einfach
die Art und Weise
von unterschiedlichen
Projekten, die nicht miteinander
zu tun haben und nicht miteinander koordiniert werden.
Das ist einfach so. Das ist gut
und schlecht gleichermaßen.
Es ist gut, das bringt gute
Software hervor für technisch basierte Nutzer,
das bringt vielfältige Software
hervor, das bringt auch Nischen-
Software hervor, die man
sonst teuer kaufen müsste,
ja.
Was es halt nicht hervorbringt, ist was
gesamtheitliches, einheitliches.
Dann muss schon jemand anrücken,
wie Google und Android machen.
Da geht das auch.
Aber Android,
also ich bin immer
noch der Ansicht, wenn man Android
mit iOS vergleicht, erkennt man immer noch,
dass da, na gut,
das hat mit Linux wenig zu tun,
das ist eher die Google-Philosophie,
die Leute mal so machen und morgen mal so und dann ihre
eigenen Anwendungen nicht mehr supporten wollen.
Aber
ich glaube, Linux wird
sich nie durchsetzen,
weil es dort die Anwendungen,
die Killer-Anwendungen gibt, die es
sonst nirgendswo gibt für den normalen Anwender.
Das glaube ich einfach nicht. Wird es auch nicht
geben. Das hat sich ja schon
in allen anderen Bereichen
hat sich das ja schon durchgesetzt.
Ja, auf
jedem Toaster ist heute Linux drauf.
Auf jedem Fernseher ist
heute Linux drauf.
Auf den Ticketautomaten
auf den
auf den Ticketautomaten ist ein Raspberry Pi
drin mit Linux.
Linux ist überall.
Linux ist aber halt nicht auf dem
Casual Desktop.
Und der Casual Desktop
ist eh am Aussterben.
Den Casual Desktop gibt es kaum noch.
Es gibt das Casual Tablet und das Casual Smartphone.
Casual Tablet und das Casual Smartphone.
Und es gibt den Gaming-Rechner
mit Windows drauf.
Das heißt, das Einzige, wo ich mir es wirklich
vorstellen könnte,
ich könnte es eigentlich eins zu eins nehmen und in ein Video packen,
oder?
Das wird wahrscheinlich auch gut für YouTube eignen.
Das Einzige, wo ich
mir wirklich vorstellen könnte,
dass ich Linux
breit nochmal durchsetzen würde auf den
Rechnern, die die Leute daheim stehen haben,
ist
über die Gaming-Schiene.
Aber das ist das Einzige.
Und in technischen
Sachen hat es sich ja schon
durchgesetzt.
Ich habe auf der Arbeit auch einen Linux-Laptop.
Leute, die im Netzwerk-Bereich arbeiten,
haben auch Linux. Ganz klar.
Leute, die Anwendungen entwickeln,
Web-Anwendungen, irgendwelche Server-Software,
ist egal. Leute, die programmieren,
die haben sau oft auch Linux
als Arbeitsumgebung.
Das sei denn, sie werden irgendwie gezwungen, Windows zu verwenden.
Überall da ist Linux ja schon
angekommen. Das ist aber halt nicht
der, ähm,
sagen wir mal,
der Casual-Noob-Rechner
daheim, den vielleicht noch irgendwie
einer da stehen hat, weil er regelmäßig mal
seine Lottozahlen nachgucken will, oder
E-Mails schreiben will, oder weil die Oma
nachgucken will,
wer ihre Freundin auf Facebook geschrieben hat.
Da wird's
auch nie Linux drauf geben.
Zumindest nicht breit.
Ja, äh,
nicht mehr so viel zu diesem Thema.
Ähm,
ja, die RMV-Ticket-Automaten
laufen auch auf Linux.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob sie da offiziell jemals
was dazu gesagt haben. Ja!
Die neuen RMV-Ticket-Automaten
laufen nach Raspberry Pi. Ich weiß, ich weiß.
Ja, das siehst du.
Wenn die Dinger manchmal booten, siehst du
bei unseren Ticket-Automaten ein Raspberry-Logo
und Linux booten.
Ich bin also nicht der Einzige, der das schon gesehen hat.
Ja, sowas ist
das schon angekommen.
In manchen Fällen funktioniert das,
aber, ähm,
das funktioniert dann aber auch nur, wenn die Leute jemanden
technisch basierten daheim haben, der ihnen
das installiert und vielleicht noch die ein oder anderen Sachen
erzählen kann. Wo es halt niemals funktionieren
wird, ist, wie gesagt,
der, der Casual
Benutzer, der daheim
sitzt, sich seine Tune-Up-Tools
installiert, ab und zu mal
irgendwie auf Steam was kauft, was spielt,
äh, Facebook
guckt,
äh, mal ein paar Fotos bearbeitet,
irgendwie ein paar rote Augeneffekte macht,
so, die versuchen ja ab und zu
mal auf Linux umzusteigen, scheitern
aber einfach daran, weil sie,
weil sie mit der Erwartung drangehen,
dass das quasi ein besseres Windows wär.
Ist halt nicht so.
Und an, an so, an so
noobfreundlicher
Standardsoftware fehlt's halt unter Linux
auch. Äh, Blockwatcher,
klar, warum nicht?
Furry Pie ist super für so'n Ticketautomat.
Gut, Chat.
Ja, ähm,
deswegen, wie gesagt, ich glaube, wenn schon, kommt
das, kommt das über die Gaming, Gaming-Ecke.
Hast du das neue
Wind-Dreck-Design von
Build 1903
gesehen? Äh,
1903 gesehen, 1903.
Hahaha.
Lol.
Ähm, ich persönlich
habe das kurz bekommen. Äh, das ist,
das ist das,
das neueste Windows hier, was ich,
was ich drauf hab.
Ähm, das einzige,
was mir aufgefallen ist,
dass das Startmenü jetzt so komisch ist.
Also, wenn ich jetzt hier suche,
so irgendwie, hallo,
dann, äh,
ist das Startmenü
irgendwie so hier da.
Das ist aber das einzige, was mir aufgefallen
ist am neuen Windows-Design.
Ansonsten, finde ich, sieht das genauso aus wie vorher.
Oder was meinste?
Gamer 329.
CubeOS, ne, hab ich noch nicht ausprobiert.
Ja, OneNote, ich finde OneNote
auch gut. Das einzige Problem ist halt,
wie ich schon gesagt hab, dass du OneNote all in,
all in musst, weißt du?
Wenn du
OneNote verwendest überall, bisschen so wie Evernote,
äh, da ist halt kein Plaintext
mehr da. Du musst halt halt OneNote überall verwenden.
Es gibt keinen gescheiten Linux-Client, es gibt,
es gibt, äh, oder korrigiert mich, wenn ich falsch
liege, ja, ähm, es gibt
nen Web-Client, nen OneNote Web-Client.
Office 365
unter Linux, aber ansonsten,
ist die Suche immer noch brauchenweise.
Ich verwende die Suche unter Windows nicht.
Hast du eigentlich noch Kontakt zu Dr.
Kabo? Ganz selten.
Was aber nicht an ihm liegt, sondern an mir.
Weil ich da voller Spaß bin
und, äh, mich irgendwie nicht melde
bei den Leuten. Was hältst du von
GoG Galaxy? Du meinst diesen neuen,
du meinst das neue, was alle anderen, äh,
Clients irgendwie integrieren
soll. Find ich ist ne gute Idee, hab ich
aber noch nicht ausprobiert. Oh, guck mal,
der Bug ist wieder da. Der Bug
ist wieder da. Oder liegt der
Bug an den Emotes? Das kann aber natürlich
auch sein. Nee, ich hab
echt da, ich hab da nen Bug drinne.
Warum hast du immer ne 1 in die Uhrleiste?
Hast du Ticks? Äh, da gibt's
nen Kommando für. Mach mal Ausrufezeichen
1. Da wird das erklärt.
Also, ja, ich hab sie nicht mehr
alle in der App-Richtung. Ich mach immer 1 und kopier
die dann.
Ausrufezeichen 1.
Ein 1 ausgeschrieben.
Äh, Max, magst du
jetzt Skype allgemein nicht oder Skype
for Business? Ich, also, ich
mag Skype allgemein nicht, aber ich hasse
Skype for Business.
Du bist der Crap. Ah, nice
Moon Eater Barco, seh ich ja jetzt erst.
Mach ne eigene Firma, AdWords.
Hab ich doch schon. Stimmt, wollt ich,
ja. Hast du ein L-Pick?
Nein, ich hab kein L-Pick.
Das ist so ne Linux-Zertifizierung.
Wenn du mal richtige
Abenteuer erleben willst, musst du dir
IT-Stellenanzeigen bei VW angucken.
Das machen wir das nächste Mal.
Okay. Ein Blur-Effekt,
ne Anmeldemaske, kann sein. Also, ich
hab jetzt, äh, großer Unterschied ist mir gar nicht aufgefallen im letzten
Windows-Update. Wolltest du
nicht irgendwas wegen Discord zeigen?
Nö, wir haben jetzt nen Discord. Mach mal Ausrufezeichen Discord.
Wir haben jetzt nen Discord.
Wir haben jetzt einen.
MaxFPS-Wubblors
Discord.
Da ist er. Wir haben's absichtlich
übersichtlich gehalten. Das da unten
seht ihr alles gar nicht.
Äh, wir haben's absichtlich übersichtlich gehalten.
Äh, es gibt, es gibt, es gibt nen
Channel für Programmiergeschichten,
nen Channel für Heimautomatisierung und wenn irgendjemand
selber irgendwas braucht.
Wir haben, äh, Themenvorschläge für Videos
und Streams.
Ankündigungen von mir.
Und, äh, allgemeines, wo man
alles mögliche Zeug beschwätzen kann,
wo man Bock drauf hat. Gibt auch keine
Sachen, die man nicht besprechen darf. Es sei denn,
ich stell mal irgendwann fest, Leute
schreiben sich da komische Dinger, dann muss ich, muss ich
mir was überlegen.
Oh, so ein Looking-for-Group-Chat für Games. Also, wir haben's
sehr übersichtlich gehalten.
Ja, und wie gesagt, ich bin auch drauf.
Guck mal, hier sind sie schon wieder am Proggers
diskutieren.
Oder wenn hier einer Programmierhilfe braucht.
Ja.
Also, wenn ihr wollt, Ausrufezeichen Discord.
Dann gibt's den,
gibt's den Invite-Link.
Komische Dinge passieren jetzt schon im
Weeb-Channel. Im Weeb-Channel
dürfen meinetwegen, äh, ähm,
komische Dinge passieren.
Da guckt das Sibaho rein, der sorgt dafür, dass es
nicht gar so komisch ist.
Oder nicht illegal komische
wird.
Und ansonsten könnt ihr da machen, was
ihr wollt. Monkratos,
genau. Achso, Gamer329,
okay. Äh,
ja, okay, das kann sein. Ich hab halt
Windows-Default-Design. Ganz im Gegensatz,
Windows lässt sich auch irgendwie,
finde ich, schlecht customizen. Ich mein, guckt euch
mal hier an, wie schön man so einen
i3-Desktop machen kann, ja.
Mit den unterschiedlichen Desktops
oben, mit den unterschiedlichen Icons, mit dem
Transparentes, mit der transparenten
Leiste, mit der Stats
Anzeige, mit den, mit den Dark
Themes, mit nem ordentlichen Terminal,
mit ner ordentlichen, ordentlichen schönen Schriftart.
Ähm, ja.
Lässt sich einfach viel schöner,
viel schöner customizen,
ja, auch ordentliches Farbschema,
also lässt sich einfach viel schöner customizen
wie Windows. Was ist
das für ein i3-Bar? Das ist
i3-Status Rust, heißt
das, glaube ich.
i3-Status Rust, ja. Wir können übrigens
mal nen, ein Paket-Update
machen, bei der Gelegenheit.
Wurde heute Bad Company 3
diskutiert? Äh,
nee, weil da
gab's nicht allzu, da gibt's nicht allzu viel zu
diskutieren, weil es gibt ja noch
nix großartiges drüber. Neues.
Außer, dass es halt eben wahrscheinlich
als 2020 mit der PS5
kommt, aber da müssen wir mal abwarten.
Oh, guck mal, gibt's sogar Update
von. Hast du dir mal
das Windows Subsystem für Linux
angeschaut und wenn ja, was hältst du davon?
Ich find's, ich find's vom Ansatz her ziemlich
gut. Es hat halt noch
einige Einschränkungen.
Zum Beispiel kannst du keine Sachen mounten und sowas.
Und die Performance lässt
auch noch ein bisschen zu wünschen übrig. Da bin ich mir
aber nicht ganz sicher, ob das an WSL
liegt oder ob das an
dem, an dem Microsoft Terminal
liegt. Und, ähm, das
Zusammenspiel zwischen
Windows-Programm und Linux-Programm ist natürlich
auch nicht so gut. Wird's wahrscheinlich
nie sein, ja. Also, es,
es geht zum Beispiel nicht ohne weiteres,
dass ich, ähm,
in der Shell
was von einem Linux-Kommando zu einem Windows-Kommando
pipe oder so.
Ja, Gamer329, so ist es.
Ich bin auch mal auf WSL 2 gespannt.
Ja. Ich schreib
mir das auf. Wir müssen, wir, wir, wir basteln,
wir basteln demnächst
wirklich mal eine Qt-Anwendung.
Also keine,
keine Qt-Chat-Anwendung, sondern eine
Qt-Anwendung.
Was Simples und gucken mal, ob, äh,
das gut funktioniert. Da können sich
die ganzen C++-Leute freuen.
Hast du Borg in WSL
getestet? Ja, funktioniert.
Funktioniert. Ups.
Was macht denn das Paket-Update? Oh, Paket-Update
ist fertig. Oh, guck mal, sogar
die neuen, äh, iPhone
Drivers sind, sind
mit drauf. Übrigens
sehr praktisch hier, die,
diese, äh, warum auch immer es
iDevice-Installer heißt.
Das ist eigentlich, ähm, ist das eine
Software, mit dem man sein iPhone
mounten kann auf Linux.
Also braucht man kein iTunes und
Gedöns. Einfach iPhone
mounten und man kann auf alles zugreifen. Auf Bilder,
auf, äh, gespeicherte Notizen
von Anwendungen und sowas. Sehr
praktisch.
Was hältst du von Minimalist-
Distros wie Arch oder Gentoo?
Beziehungsweise Minimalist-Software
wie MPD oder die ganzen CLI-Dinger?
Äh, ja.
Verwende ich ja auch, also.
Ich find das gut. Ich find das, ich find das gut, wenn sich
die Sachen aufs Wesentliche konzentrieren.
Manchmal darf's halt aber auch ruhig mal
ein bisschen, ähm, ein bisschen
ausgefallener sein. Ja, also wenn es zum Beispiel
nen To-Do-Notiz, sonst was
Programm ist, klingt erstmal super
simpel, darf aber ruhig schon ein paar ordentliche
Funktionen haben. Gibt's leider
zu wenig gute. Eigentlich
gar kein gutes. Na klar braucht man
extra Treiber für, was meinst, wie, wie,
wie du sonst nen iPhone mounten willst.
Also ich mein, du kannst das
öffnen als USB-Gerät, das ist kein
Problem. Aber
wenn du jetzt beispielsweise auf deine
Notizanwendung zugreifen willst,
ähm,
dann geht das nur, wenn du das als, als
mit Apple-spezifischen Sachen
mountest. Weil das kannst du ja sonst auch
nicht sehen im, im Explorer oder so.
Also, es ist 22 Uhr, Leute.
Ich bleib noch kurz on, also ich seh nicht,
dass ich jetzt instant off gehe. Ähm,
die Nextcloud-Installation
machen wir morgen.
Ähm, das hat
heut nicht ganz
hingehauen.
Wir waren heut mit sehr, mit anderen
Dingern beschäftigt. So Max
Sidetracks war wieder am Start.
Drei Stunden. Aber ich würd sagen,
nichtsdestotrotz waren wir heute
relativ, äh,
produktiv, ja, mit dem, was wir gemacht haben.
Also wir haben, wir haben
wenigstens was gemacht.
Also das mit den Stellenanzeigen,
ähm, wenn ihr wollt, können wir das öfters
machen. Ich glaub, das ist ein ganz, das ist
ne ganz gute Sache, die man immer so zum,
so zur Belustigung
einstreuen kann. Ähm,
ab und zu mal.
Und sich angucken, was sich
die Leute da wieder eingedacht haben, äh, wieder
ausgedacht haben.
Und ihr wollt Q-Chat, ja.
Das ist viel besser platziert da unten, oder?
Das muss ich auch mal
in meinem Tool updaten, dass man
Positionen pro Bild speichern kann
und nicht nur global.
Der Chat verdeckt's, oh.
Verdammte. Chat verdeckt's,
das geht ja gar nicht.
Aber das ist Q-Chat.
Q-Chat kann eigentlich nix verdecken.
Haben wir noch was?
Also wie gesagt, mit Nextcloud
Installation anfangen muss ich jetzt nicht.
Achso, ich kann mal gucken, ob's mein Raspberry
mittlerweile eingekriegt hat, dass
der da ist. Ah ja, okay.
Haben die?
Haben die Nextcloud in den Repos
wahrscheinlich nicht, ne?
Denk ich mal nicht.
Also wenn ihr noch was wissen wollt, oder wenn noch irgendwie was, äh,
was ist, haut's raus in Chat.
Ich bin auch kurz da.
Na, Docker Install.
Docker Nextcloud Install war auch sowas, was ich nicht
gemacht habe, weil sie damals Probleme
mit Updates hatten. Und gerade
Docker, lustigerweise, ja, unter anderem
die easyste
Plattform ist, was zu updaten schlechthin.
Darf ich mit schlafen kommen?
Das kommt drauf an.
Wenn du ein hottes
Gaming-Grill bist, 18 plus,
dann können wir uns
da nochmal drüber unterhalten.
Wobei, 18 plus,
sagen wir mal, sagen wir mal,
sagen wir mal 25 plus.
Achso, na dann.
Und da darf ich jetzt ja nix dagegen sagen,
weil sonst ist die Anzeige wieder raus.
Oh, der Busfahrer,
der Busfahrer überzeugt, ja.
Der Sbarro,
beim Sbarro ist 16 okay, der ist selber,
der ist selber nicht so alt.
Bis bald 21, ja nee, dann nicht.
Dann ist
MonkaTOS angesagt. Warum hab ich
eigentlich kein MonkaTOS bei mir
im... Was?
Moment, es gibt
einen Nextcloud? Ich hab den Nextcloud schon dabei?
Ach nee,
dass der Desktop kleint.
Moment, MonkaTOS.
Hatte jemand
ein schönes, transparentes, hochauflösendes
MonkaTOS-Bild?
Das da, das ist zu klein.
Das ist zu klein.
Monka
MonkaTOS.
Naja,
besser als nix, oder?
Ich hab MonkaTOS noch nicht mal
aktuell aktiviert im Chat.
Okay, es gibt kein Nextcloud bei denen.
Dome Frage,
wieso geht Control-C und Control-V
im Terminal nicht?
Weil Control-C, weil die
schon anders belegt sind.
Weil Control-C
ist den aktuell laufenden
Befehl abbrechen und
Control-V ist glaube ich
standardmäßig nichts.
Aber Control-C ist
Befehl abbrechen.
Du musst,
du kannst machen
Strg-Shift-C
und Strg-Shift-V.
Ja, wir brauchen uns auf Herespion.
Nextcloud.
Warum mach ich das jetzt eigentlich doch?
Das wollte ich doch erst morgen machen.
Da strobelt Stefan.
Jaja, blablabla.
Ja gut, das ist immer noch das klassische
Tar runterladen und nach
www.html
entpacken.
Wir machen das mit sqlite zum testen.
Keine MariaDB oder sonst was.
Das gefällt
im Chat. Cute Chat.
Copy link location.
Ah, www.html.
Ah so.
Nicht da.
Ja dann,
installen wir mal
ein Nginx.
Was hältst du eigentlich von Postgres?
Beste, beste Open Source Datenbank.
Postgres beste.
Alter lan.
Ne, aber ohne Scheiß.
Postgres beste Datenbank.
Die es Open Source mäßig so gibt.
Relationale Datenbank.
Ach so.
Wir könnten vielleicht mal WireGuard
wieder deinstallieren.
Andererseits juckt es auch nicht, wenn es an ist.
Ne, das machen wir mal neu.
Das machen wir mal neu.
Mit Nextcloud.
Dauert sonst zu lang.
Schon mal von ArangoDB gehört?
Nope.
Es gibt mittlerweile so viele
NoSQL Datenbanken.
Es war klar, dass es eine NoSQL Datenbank ist.
Was sonst?
Habe ich aber nichts von gehört.
Hast du eine Meinung
zu OpenSSL?
Ja, ohne geht es nicht.
Warum auf dem Raspberry?
Zum testen.
Ich könnte es mir auch in einem Container
lokal installieren oder so.
Aber den Raspberry haben wir eh noch hier dran von gestern.
Ich muss den übrigens
noch mal starten und den Raspberry
ordentlich runterfahren.
Weil wenn Raspberrys eins nicht mögen,
dann ist einfach Strom rausziehen.
Dann dürfen wir morgen gleich die SD-Karte neu machen.
Power off.
Bam.
So, jetzt können wir die
VM ausschalten.
Übrigens, ich muss euch
jetzt noch mal hier was
loswerden an den cute Chat.
Ich finde das echt toll, wie viele Leute immer am Start
sind, ohne dass ich das irgendwo ankündige
oder sonst was. Und, äh,
wie viele Leute sich hier für so
Technik-Krams tatsächlich interessieren.
Hier ist auch ein großer Anteil an,
oder ein hoher Anteil an Leuten, die sich tatsächlich
auskennen mit dem ein oder anderen Thema.
Das ist sehr nice.
Ich würde sagen, das ist einzigartig in Deutschland.
Das gibt es gefühlt sonst nirgendswo.
Ich will nicht sagen, dass es
sonst keine Technik-Sachen gibt, aber
wo wirklich ein hoher Anteil an Leute ist,
die sich auskennen, das gibt es eigentlich so gut wie nirgendswo.
Ja, Quinn
gibt es immer. Ist auch nicht schlimm.
Vielleicht wird es dich interessiert.
Vielleicht lernst du ja was. Das wäre natürlich
ganz besonders toll noch.
Aber du bist natürlich jederzeit auch als
Ahnungsloser willkommen.
Genau.
Wir sind führend in der
Technik-Streaming-Branche.
Weltweit
führend.
Führend im deutschsprachigen
Raum.
Und schnell wachsend. Ja.
Ja.
Das müsste ich mir echt ins Profil schreiben.
Der Chat ist dynamically
programmed.
Und agil. Auch neuer.
Der Partnerantrag, den wollte ich eigentlich nach dem Stream
machen, aber den habe ich, ist so spät jetzt schon.
Taugt
Nextcloud16 was?
Die Frage konnten wir
noch nicht abschließend beantworten. Das werden wir morgen
machen. Stimmt, agil ist
auf deutsch ist schlecht. Agile.
Ja, ja. Agile.
Cliffhanger, richtig.
Obolchops,
warum habe ich das eigentlich noch offen?
Oh, ne. Das
PPGA Board ist ja kaputt jetzt.
Ich habe ja die VM ausgeschaltet.
Das läuft ja in der VM.
Wir sind, genau.
Wir sind nicht das
Center of Excellence, wir sind das Center of
Debating.
VM ist aus. Bei diesen Titeln
kannst du auch Katja Grasawitze, kannst du auch
ApoRed gucken. DIGA!
Oder was?
Was sagt er sonst noch immer?
Ähm
Lass mal kurz meinen inneren ApoRed channelen.
DIGA! Kritische Hase, meine Freunde.
Das war doch jetzt ziemlich
original, oder?
Das hat es doch ganz gut getroffen.
Discord löschen.
Ich sehe, ihr seid nicht die passende
Zielgruppe, äh
anscheinend. Ja?
JSP64
Das ist echt so.
Ich kenne auch in Deutschland keinen. Also, es gibt
jede Menge Channels auf YouTube,
die sich, sagen wir mal,
Technik-Channels in dem Sinn
nennen. Ähm
Aber
Die machen dann
Smartphone-Reviews oder sowas.
Ich will nicht sagen, dass Smartphones keine Technik
sind. Ähm
Aber für mich ist das
ist das kein Technik-Channel.
Ja? Linus Technips
ist für mich auch so an der Grenze.
Da geht es, also
vom Inhalt her ist es
halt, ist aber ist
kommen technische Sachen in den Videos
vor. Es ist aber, es ist
Technik-Entertainment. Ja?
Und das macht er auch so gut wie sonst keiner.
Ähm
Ich sprich da auch nicht umsonst
so viel an. Ja?
Ähm. Ich gucke nicht oft, aber wenn
ich gucke, finde ich es eigentlich immer, immer lustig und gut
gemacht. Der Bauer gibt's
noch, genau. Der macht, was Hardware angeht, ähm
ziemlich gute Videos.
Es gibt auch ein paar kleinere Channels, die
Sachen programmieren und machen.
Ähm. Aber sowas in der
Richtung hier gibt's eigentlich
nicht. Also Leute,
habt ihr das gehört? Wir sind, äh,
führend, führend und schnell wachsen
im deutschsprachigen Raum.
Industrie-Leading, genau.
Rampage
67 sagt, es gibt auf Twitch
einen Kanal, was Cannabis-Zucht zeigt.
Ey, es gibt auch einen Kanal, der eine Kamera an seinem
3D-Drucker drin hat und im Titel
eine Frage drinstehen hat, was wird das?
Und, äh, ich weiß nicht, ob man was gewinnen kann,
wenn man das errät. Es gibt auf
Twitch, also vor allem, wenn man mal auch mal hier in
Science & Technology und so guckt,
gucken wir doch grad mal. Wir müssen demnächst
mal eh jemand hosten.
Ähm.
Gibt's auch ganz gute
deutschsprachige Sachen.
Es gibt sogar auf Twitch, ähm,
im deutschsprachigen Raum hab ich letztens
gesehen, es gibt sogar ein paar
Mädels, die, die, die
Programmier-Streams machen.
Hab ich mir gedacht, was ist denn hier kaputt?
Ganz, ganz
seltene, äh,
Sachen. Ja.
Haselmeier, das stimmt. Es gibt auch
genug Channels mittlerweile, ähm,
auf Twitch, was Gaming anbelangt,
ähm,
von Mädels, wo es
nicht um Bootcamp geht.
Gott sei Dank, ey, das hat lange genug gedauert.
Radion AX
XT-Kühler-Upgrade.
Ah, da wollen wir mal gucken.
Das sieht auf jeden Fall MonkaS aus.
Ja, bei der Vega
das ist echt dringend.
Wollen wir den hosten?
Oh, German Bash
Scripting.
Bash Scripting in Atom.
Ist auch mal was Neues. Wobei,
ist das überhaupt Atom? Nee, das ist, das ist
VS Code.
Komm, nee, wir hosten, wir hosten, wir hosten
den Kühler-Upgrader.
Also, Leute, benehmt euch
ordentlich. Benehmt
euch ordentlich und, äh,
wünscht ihr mal, dass es nicht Monka
Smoked?
Wir sehen uns morgen. Macht's gut.
Bis denn. See you.